тихеньку будемо
розпочинати
частини людей ще немає сподіваємося
будуть підтягатися можливо через погодні
умови Можливо ще через інші колапси
природного чи неприродного техногену
характеру Але я вірю в те
що нас
побільшає радий вітати всіх сьогодні моє
ім'я Ігор хворостян і я керівник
шкільного директорату Міністерства
освіти і науки
України незважаючи на отакий
зимовосірий ранок ще раз радію що ми
зібралися тут в тісному
колі шановні пані та
панове коференцію вважаємо нашу семінар
наший у форматі рівний Рівному відкритим
Я коротко розкажу про нашу мету наша
мета досить амбітна Впродовж цих двох
днів познайомитися з цікавими найкращими
практиками профільної старшої школи
сьогодні впродовж першого дня Це буде
п'ять країн Англія Естонія Німеччина
Польща Так кого є
Франція сьогодні більш такий
інформативний семінар Я хочу зауважити
що спочатку будуть виступи представників
відповідних країн з їхніми доповідями а
потім після цих виступів Ви матимете
нагоду поставити запитання завтра другий
день У нас більш інтерактивний ми в
тісному форматі будемо пропрацьовувати і
виробляти ці цікаві ідеї збирати інсайти
і цікаві рішення для поступу української
вже старшої профільної освіти тож е аби
не забирати багато часу Дозвольте е перш
за все подякувати організації
економічного співробітництва та розвитку
і зокрема андреасові шляйхеру а також
нашим партнерам з юніicef за допомогу в
організації і проведенні цього семінару
і надати слово міністрові освіти і науки
України оксенові Васильовичу Лісовому
пане оксене Я бачу ви вже з нами тож
радо передаю вам
слово дякую і
дякую дуже радий вітати представників
міжнародної освітянської спільноти
Шановні
колеги Вітаю всіх в відкритті цього
міжнародного семіна
ру обговорення моделей старшої
профільної школи надзвичайно важливе для
нас сьогодні оскільки перед нами в
Україні стоїть завдання визначити модель
яка дозволить учням робити усвідовний
вибір формувати власну освітн траєкторію
Ми дуже вдячні організації економічного
сбницва та розвитку за підтримку
унікальну експертизу яку ми маємо на
шляху реалізації ці
ціні також вдячні icef за підтримку в
проведенні цього
семінару реформа українська школа займає
центральне місце в нашій освітній
стратегії і ми прагнемо створити систему
освіти яка була б зосереджена на
особистості дитини на розвитку
компетенцій які допоможуть досягти
успіху в XX столітті це передбачає не
лише акодемічні знання як відомо а і
навички критичного мислення креативності
комунікативності співпраці саме тому
одним із ключових рішень є визначення
найбільш ефективної та гнучкої моделі
старшої профільної школи і ми розуміємо
що освіта - це не просто передача знань
фундамент для майбутнього кожної людини
е де і для всієї
нації сьогоднішній семінар вправна точка
для діалогу і обміну досвіду який
допоможе нам у формуванні ефективної
сучасної
конкурентноспроможної системи профільної
освіти майбутнє нашої країни залежить
від інвестицій в освіту від розвитку та
підтримки молодого
покоління я дякую кожному за участь за
готовність долучити до процесу Я дуже
дякую за підтримку Я дуже сподіваюсь що
цей цикл заходів цей семінар підходить
до цього циклу допоможе нам сформувати
освітнє середовище часу у нас дуже мало
ці рішення виклики перед нами стоять
жнні значні але це не привід відкладати
дуже важливу і нагальну для України
реформу тому і ще раз дякую вам всім за
те що приєднались і сподіваюся на
ефективну
роботу Дякую щиро оксени васильови
А тепер Дозвольте запросити до слова
Андрія борисовича Сташкова Андрію
борисовичу якщо можна Дякую на сцену а
також Андреаса
шляйхера директора
andдрес директор Департаменту напрямку
освіти і навичок в
уср він опікувався програмаю оцінювання
міжнародних учнів це програма Піза і
останні 20 років андреспрацював з
міністрами керівниками в сфері освіти по
всьому світу для того щоби покращити
якість освіти і доступ до освіти
шляйхера відоме ім'я і відомий друг і
України і всієї системи освіти а також
нашого заступника міністра не потрібно
Зараз коротко вони матимуть свої
доповіді розпочне Андрій Борисович е
прошу запустити презентацію на
екран Андрій Борисович розповість про
поступ реформи нової української школи
зокрема в контексті того що стосується
старшої профільної школи профільної
освіти Дякую та Дякую пане Ігорю Вітаю
всіх учасників семінару Я думаю що цих
два дні яких ми маємо працювати над тією
моделлю старшої профільної школи яку ми
будемо впроваджувати уже з 2027 року
насправді
ее будуть корисними і ми зможемо досягти
якогось консенсусу оскільки рішень
бачень ее в моделі насправді є дуже
багато Я думаю що той міжнародний досвід
про який говорив пан Ігор про те що ми
будемо мати можливість послухати як
старша профільна школа
функціонує в наших сусідів буде
надзвичайно корист
я ж спробую зупинитися і
охарактеризувати те бачення старшої
профільної школи яке є на даний момент в
Міністерстві освіти над чим ми працюємо
що вже в принципі окреслено і що може
бути взяте за основу в напрацюванні
подальших кроків провадження саме
старшої профільної школи
Отож і слайди
є реформа
старшої профільної школи - це невід'ємна
частина реформи нової української школи
яка почалася ще в 2017 році зі старту
пілоту а в 2018 році з масового з
масової
практики в
школах і відповідно до бачення
впровадження цієї реформи ми маємо в
2027 році почати уже її впроваджувати в
усіх школах України
реформа нової української школи - це
основна реформа Міністерства освіти над
якими ми зараз працюємо всі інші реформи
так таким чи іншим чином пов'язані з нею
але по
факту саме реформа нуж це є основна
реформа
і основна її Мета - це покращити якість
освіти ви бачите принципи нуж їх є
багато це є основні це є компетентнісні
підхід пхід в навчанні це індивідуальний
підхід до кожного учня що важливо буде
саме в старшій профільній школі коли ми
будемо говорити про індивідуальні
освітні траєкторії звичайно
інклюзивність та рівність доступу до
освіти активне навчання інноваційні
методи навчання формування цінностей
особливо важливо цінностей які ми
говоримо про які ми говоримо під час
війни цінностей національного
патріотичного виховання та інших
цінностей обов'язково повинні врахувати
те що при впровадженні реформи старшої
профільної школи важливо є співпраця з
батьками ее і громадами це тими хто
визначають і фінансують на даний момент
е школу і не забувати про професійний
розвиток
вчителів в нас є декілька
стейкхолдерів заради яких ми
впроваджуємо цю реформу і передусім в
центрі в центрі реформи має стояти в нас
учень або учениця саме розвиток
компетентностей учнів учениць є на
основним в реформі нової української
школи крім того вчителі та вчительки це
ті хто закладають основи знань в наших
учнів тому саме їхній професійний
розвиток їхні е підготовка це є те що
має бути обов'язково в впроваджено в
реформі старшої профільної школи коли ми
говоримо про старшу профільну школу ми
маємо розуміти що це висококваліфіковані
освідчені вчителі які
ее якісно ее вчать наших дітей і
використовують різні методи та методики
при своїй
роботі батьки та адміністрація шкіл - це
також стейкхолдери з якими ми повинні
працювати і думку яких ми повинні
враховувати часто ми чуємо від батьків
що вони не знають що робиться в школі і
що їх їхні діти
отримують під час проведення уроків
важливо щоби комунікація школи з
батьками залишалася досить активною і
при
цьому не може бути якісної ефективної
школи якщо це школа не є автономною в
нас в законі Про освіту передбачено
автономія шкіл це є Академічна це є
фінансова це інша автономія шкіл але на
жаль вона не в всіх випадках впроваджена
Якщо ж ми будемо говорити про старшу
профільну школу ми повинні говорити що
це повністю автономні заклади освіти
керівники яких мають повноваження
приймати відповідні рішення щодо і
зарплат вчителів
щодо різних
фінансових операцій які вони хочуть
робити щодо того яким чином вчителі
підвищують кваліфікацію як школа працює
як школа
функціонує до чого ми прагнемо в
трансформації системи шкільної
профільної освіти передусім це думаю
зрозуміло і відо домо усім трьохрічна
освіта
профільна Тобто ми переходимо з
двохрічного навчання на трьохріч в
старшій профільній школі це перший рік
зрозуміло адаптаційний після закінчення
базової школи в подальшому це вже
профільність навчання вибору
предметів можливість гнучко формувати ці
профілі в залежності від того як хоче
дитина і також її батьки тому що зараз в
нас насправді є проблема з цим і
фактично профілів які можливо
застосувати В теперішній старшій школі
їх є 27 але по факту
вибирають незначну їх кількість і
фактично 72% учнів навчаються тільки за
п'ятьма
профілями Крім того ми зараз вже знаєте
працюємо над стандартом старшої
профільної школи маємо стандарт базової
і виставлене публічне обговорення
стандарт старшої профільної школи
Звичайно Це є кращ ніж той варіант коли
в нас є один стандарт для п'ятих-11-х
класів і
ее до наступність цих стандартів і
поступу прогресу кожного учня в нас має
бути збережена від дошкілля яке плавно
переходить в початкову школу в базову і
старшу профільну школу Саме ці стандарти
нам дозволять це
зробити ви бачите що буде в кінці е
закінчення 12-го класу це конкретні
результати навчання які будуть виписані
в
стандарті на рівні
орієнтирнів для оцінювання ці результати
відповідно будуть прописані і для кожної
освітньої галузі в нас буде визначений
компетентність і
потенціал як як профілі взагалі можуть
функціонувати в старшій профільній школі
в нас є передбачено дев'ять освітніх
стандартів галузей точніше з яких можна
формувати профіль
точно базовий навчальний план буде мати
години для вільного вибору предметів і
чим більше годин таких в нас буде для
вільного вибору тим легше і гнучкіше
можна буде пристосовувати ті
профілі для тієї для того запиту який
буде йти від учнів та від їхніх
батьків мінімальна кількість годин
обов'язково повинна бути визначена
Оскільки ми будемо говорити про
основні досягнення за навчанням
а всі інші години які ми пропонуємо до
вільного вибору вони повинні бути
розподілені на ті предмети які хочуть
учні причому важливо розуміти що ми
хочемо щоб в старшій профільній
школі в нас години на вивчення освітніх
галузей розподілялися за роками а не за
тижнями як зараз Тобто ми будемо мати
можливість протягом
року викладати модулі в певні курси і
облік цих годин буде йти за роками що
значно полегшить і дозволить гнучко
підходити до формування саме
е-е розкладу і предметів які
викладаються освітні галузі які є в
стандартні не буду зупинятися ви всі їх
знаєте на на на основі яких будуть саме
формуватися профілі не обов'язково
конкретний профіль конкретна галузь тут
можна поєднювати і говорити про те що
різні профілі різні галузі можуть бути
поєднані в одному профілі і також з
окремих галузей різні предмети можуть
надаватися учню Як предмети за вибором
як же ми будемо як як як виглядає карта
впровадження самої реформи те про що я
говорив на початку 17-18-й рік - це є
запуск нової української школи зараз Ми
є в шостому класі
впровадженні реформи і в 2025 році
насправді це є нове порівняно з
пілотом початкової та базової освіти на
два роки швидше ми плануємо почати Пілот
саме старшої профільної
школи два роки пілоту насправді це є
виклик для всієї системи освіти до цього
ми мали рік і насправді було складно два
роки це буде ще складніше по-перше в нас
є набагато менше часу на підготовку саме
пілоту старшої профільної школи але це з
другого з іншого боку дасть нам
можливість пропілотувати як навчальні
матеріали методичні
матеріали і внести до них зміни за
необхідності тобто Зараз ми коли
пілотуємо навчальні матеріали ми
фактично під час пілоту уже починаємо
замовляти самі підручники затверджувати
модельні навчальні програми два роки
пілоту дасть можливість не просто
пропілотувати але ще й внести зміни якщо
будеть в цьому необхідність і вже в 2027
році ми
почнемо основну реформу старшій
профільній школі це ті діти які зараз
навчаються в шостому класі і почнуть
навчатися в 10-му і закінчать вони школу
в 2030 році хочу сказати що тут Я
особисто зацікавлений в провадженні цієї
реформи в мене донька навчається якраз в
шостому класі нової української школи і
закінчить вона школу в
2030 Дякую всім за увагу і бажаю
плітного клідної роботи
дякую дякую і борисовичу ми Дозвольте
тепер передати слово андреу
шляйхру передаю слово пану шлейхеру
директору Департаменту напрямку освіти
навичок в оср будь ласка Па адресу
Почніть вашу
презентацію Доброго ранку Перепрошую що
я буду виступати англійською Вам
доведеться послухати пере клад і я би
попросив запустити мою
презентацію Я стежив за новою
українською школою від самого початку я
дійсно був вражений тим що відбувалося в
початковій школі там сталася справжня
трансформація
і для оср велика честь
бачити як відбуваються реформи тепер вже
і в старшій
школі часові рамки які ви
зазначили виглядають достатньо розлогим
але якщо Ми подумаємо то 27й рік вже не
за горами це майже завтра для нас
величезна честь стати частиною цих
реформ можете сказати А навіщо нам
змінюватися адже Україна дуже
успішнореаліз
старшу школу люди готувалися до
майбутнього працевлаштування з великими
успіхами але Світ змінюється Ви ж знаєте
раніше Можна було підготуватися до
якоїсь роботи дуже рано тому що ви вже
очікували що будете працювати на цій
роботі але зараз Треба готувати молодих
людей до роботи Яка ще не існує до
професій яких ще не з'явилося бо
з'являються нові технології так з одного
боку У нас багато технологій які
полегшують нам життя але з іншого боку
дуже складно молодій людині
орієнтуватися в цьому всесвіті
можливості проявляти гнучкість і
адаптивність змінювати свою професію
коли змінюється реальність що дуже нам
чітко
зрозуміло після війни економіка України
дуже зміниться порівняно з тим якою вона
була до війни компанії не стануть такими
як були вони будуть відновлюватися
по-іншому набуваючи нових навичок і Ми
всі будемо жити в новому світі ви
думаєте що за рахунок цифрових навичок
стало легше
навчати
адже Новий
світ вже не такий яки ми його
знали знає Зараз Google
все але тепер компетенції ідея
компетенції настільки важлива щоб учні
могли мобілізувати свої когнітивні
емоційні ресурси аби з'єднати всі точки
разом розвинути свої ідеї і це не
відбувається настільки прямолінійно по
всьому світу є багато чудових моделей
старшої профільної освіти ви можете
подивитися на укра з одного боку де
відбувається переважно вертикальна
інтеграція освіти ви обираєте профіль
далі там читеся за цим профілем і вже
настає випуск А можете подивитися на
іншому кінці шкали
це Штати там школа наче супермаркет де
можна обрати все що завгодно Але така
модель теж має свої обмеження одна мдель
дуже вузко спеціалізована і інша може
бути
достатньо складною для учнів Вона може
їх пантеличити Особливо якщо вони ще не
знають чим хочуть займатися в
майбутньому школа відіграє величезну
роль в тому щоб
допомогти учням зрозуміти до чого вони
схильні в чому їхня пристрасть школа
допомагає їм стати майстернею в тому що
важливо саме для них і також Це слугує
соціальній
меці це приносить користь нашому
суспільству і нашій
економіці Ось чому ми сьогодні
представимо вам багато моделей Вони
знаходяться скажемо так десь посередині
між дуже спеціалізованою профільною
освітою і дуже відкритою моделлю ви
можете подивитися самі як вам підійти до
цього питання
які ж
амбіції стосовно старшої
школи я три вам можу продемонструвати а
мети треба подбати про те щоб учням було
цікаво вчитися ми знаємо що вони цікаві
і їхню цікавість треба стимулювати і
заохочувати ви знаєте в минулому Ми
раніше
вчили для того щоб працювати а зараз
Навчання вже і є робота ці люди
навчаються вчитися впродовж всього
своєго життя щоби вони могли розширити
свої горизонти і в будь-який момент були
готові до прояву своєї
цікавості далі учні мають побудувати
індивідуальні шляхи до вищої освіти і
поцінованої високооплачуваної
роботи ми знаємо яка існує ієрархія в
академічній освіті і в профтех освіті
має бути вибір для молодих людей Ви
маєте визнати це молоді люди всі
навчаються по-різному і освіта має
відповідати цьому розмаїттю навчальних
потреб в першу чергу треба подбати про
те щоб молоді українські громадяни
зростали саме
громадянами щоб громадянські цінності
були не просто шкільним предметом але
способом поведінки людей і ви
знаєте про
роль старшої школи старшої профільної
школи така освіта допомагає молодим
людям
зрозуміти де вони хочуть докласти своїх
зусиль в суспільстві і в
економіці тож я би запропонував три
амбітні мети для старшої профії школи
по-перше необхідно допомогти учням
виявити свої дібності таланти сильні
сторони далі забезпечити структуроване
поглиблення навичок і у вас тепер
додався ще один рік в старшій школі і
він дає ось цей простір для того щоби
поглибити знання розширити знання
сформуватимі сток до світу праці і до
вищої освіти також Ну і третя дуже теж
важлива амбітна мета необхідно
побудувати усвідомлення світу за межами
школа часом дуже абстрактний світ
відокремлений від решти світу учні
знаходяться всередині цього світу
шкільного світу а решта лишається за
межами школи і чим більше містків ви
прокидаєте з шкільногосвіту до іншого
світу Тим більш автентичним стає
навчання тим більше воно відповідає
викликам
реальності
якщо наприклад дитина походить з
сільської місцевості де менше
можливостей То цей світ може бути дуже
маленьким бачите тільки людей навколо
себе і школа може допомогти розвинути це
зв'я із зовнішнім світом як може це
виглядати на
практики бачите Можуть бути різні шляхи
які з'єднуються по-іншому і деяким учням
треба допомогти змінити свої шляхи і
освіта має бути не тільки толерантною до
змін освітнього освітнього шляху має
дозволяти досліджувати різні можливості
бачите зараз додався один рік за цей рік
учні зможуть вивчити
різні варіанти і можливо змінять свої
освітній шлях ну отже повторимо амбіція
номер один учні визначають свої сильні
сторони і талант усвідомлюючи де вони
можуть зробити найбільший внесок в
суспільство і
також
необхідно надати учням
можливості вчитися як вшир так і в
глибину Тобто створюєте їм профіль що
означає
спеціалізацію і таким чином вони можуть
докопатися до самих глибин Мислити як
вчений як дослідник це завжди важливо ви
знаєте в Україні понад 20 профілів і це
власне
теж екстремальна ситуація у країнах осср
у більшості країн осср є від шести до
дев'яти різних профілів з об'єднанням
предметів давайте поділюся з вами
результатами дослідження Піза Я думаю це
дуже позитивно ми
розглядали наскільки учні мотивовані
навчатися наскіль Звичайно що ми зважали
у критичні умови такі як пандемія і
війна коли навчання було підірвано
бачите що учні в Україні мають кращий
показник аніж середній за країнами уср
ви можете це використати як перевагу це
одна сторона медалі але покажу вам і
іншу ми запитували учнів Чому вони
наприклад не ходять в школу Чому вони
випали шкільної освіти бачите для
України учні кажуть що їм було нудно
вони не кажуть що вони зах не могли
відвідути кажу їм було нудно щось з цим
треба робити якби ви наприклад управляли
не школою а
супермаркетом і ви би дізнались що 30 зі
100 покупців заходять і йдуть нічого не
купуючи і це стається дуже довго і ви
тоді будете робити інвентаризацію
змінювати спосіб мислення цю проблему
вирішити А ось у світі ми часто не
сприйма маємо учнів як споживачів які
використовують те що ми їм даємо ми
маємо дати учням зрозуміти що шкільне
навчання пов'язане з їхнім майбутнім з
їхнім життям надалі Отже треба їм дати
ось це відчуття
мети як це може виглядати на практиці ну
ви ж знаєте ось умови і математика
завжди будуть
основами тут вже ніяких компромісів не
можна досягти да особливо мови минулому
мови дозволяли лише отримати доступ до
знання сьогодні
це
можливість формувати
думку засвоювати різні точки зору
вивчати їх тож Мова - це основа осно но
навчання
будьде і я думаю що не всі погодяться що
те саме справедливо для математики але є
багато доказів того що математика часом
часто дозволяє зробити хороші прогнози
на майбутнє Математика - це ще одна мова
це абстрактна мова мова яка дозволяє
досягти триангуляції відобразити складні
зв'язки мов
математики ви знаєте є і інші предмети
які країни часом включаються в
обов'язкову програму А часом в
факультативну це мистецтво фізкультура
природознавче науки гуманітарні науки
тощо і знов таки часом учні можуть
обирати міжпредметами часом деякі
предмети йдуть як даність А по-перше що
вам
треба зробити аби учні отримали мету це
надати їм певні дискреційні повноваження
можливість вибору є різні моделі
і для учнів повинен з'явитися вибір в
межах
предмету наприклад ви робите якийсь
предмет обов'язковим але ви дозволяєте
учням додавати до цього предмету якісь
елементи компоненти це досить типово
наприклад для Естонії
знаєте учні можуть не можуть оббирати
такі предмет як література він є
обов'язкови але можуть поглиблювати свої
навички наприклад в ораторському
мистецтві і мистецтві веденні дебатів
тобто в межах якогось одного предмету
вже є певний вибір предмет обов'язково
проте пропонується
вибір додаткових елементів вони можуть
отримати вибіри в якихось інших сферах
ви формуєте ядро
обов'язкових предметів і до цього ядра
додаються факультативні предмети які
дозволять поглибити основні от в Польщі
наприклад треба вивчати польську мову і
математику як обов'язкові предмети але
також вони можуть обрати ще три
факультативні
предмети і тоді Виявляється що вибір
учня більше
структурований це дуже типово До речі у
Франції діяти за
галузями учні обирають собі галузь абоже
домени в межацго домену вони з гнучкістю
формують свій профіль це дуже
структурований підхід Таким чином ми
примиряємося між гнучкістю і
спрямування Отже це друга важлива
метація надання
вибору ви можете по-різному реалізувати
це на практику можуть бути домени такі
як українська мова математика іноземні
мови природознавч науки манітарні
мистецтво тощо Тобто там мають бути
якісь обов'язкові елементи обов'язковий
контент то що учні мають неодмінно
вивчити і далі можуть бути варіанти які
будуть поглиблювати або доповнювати ці
галузі все це може виглядати зовсім
по-іншому Я просто вам навожу приклад
того як взаємодіють два
виміри І я хотів би зараз перейти
до результатів
Піза ми чітко бачимо один
момент учні приходять в старшу школу не
з однаковими навичками Піза показує що
деякі учні дуже здібні мають високий
рівень навичок а інші учні безумовно
стикаються з труднощами і це реальність
яку ми маємо прийняти у учнів є різна
мотивація різні профілі навичок тощо та
й навіть навчальне середовище може бути
різними це дуже важли для учнів і Це
веде мене до наступної думки до того що
необхідно пропонувати
розмоїться
наприклад може бути обов'язкови предмет
українська але далі для поглиблення
можна пропонувати літературу і різні
літератури або ж математика загальна
математика Може поділятися на поглиблену
статистику і вищо прикладну
математику тобто на різних рівнях
викладається різний контект з
урахуванням різних інтересів і
потреб для
учнів Ну і зрештою Я хотів би додати ще
одну точку зору я би запропонував вам
поміркувати над нею а саме давайте учням
можливість виконати особисті проекти у
нас збиралася хороша показова база того
що учні в старших
класах стають більше заохочені
мотивовані якщо вони виконують свій
проект це дозволяєм встановити свої
власні чальні цілі адже вони роблять те
що цікавить саме них навчатися їм стає
цікавіше вони відчувають авторство Так
це ж мій проект я за нього відповідаю я
маю терпляче і послідовно ти до його
завершення також реалізація такого
проекту вимагає залучення різних навичок
і знань з різних предметів навчання має
бути
багатодисциплінарним але треба також
думати виходити за межі
дисциплін учням необхідно дивитися на
проблему з різних дисциплінарних точок
зору і намагатися
тренгулювати власне такий
проект ляє встановити тісний зв'язок між
учнівськими досягненнями і знаннями з
проекту часом треба залучати знання з
інших предметів з математики це
дослідження Це
додає глибини учень може самостійно
провести дослідження я вас заохочую
поміркувати над цими питаннями і давайте
подивимося як це може виглядати перше
треба зрозуміти що це цікавить учня
треба провести
дослідження який продукт може з'явитися
в результаті проекту це може бути якийсь
предмет як або якась книга публікація Ну
можливо не в 10-му класі це можна робити
бо вони ж тільки починають старшу школу
але в
11-му12-му класі це була б непогана ідея
це дозволить виявити до чого схиляються
учні і хочу зробити одне застерження Не
думайте що для учителів Це так просто
учителів треба скеровати інструктувати
аби вони могли правильно координувати
виконання проектів мотивуючи і
направляючи учнів тож
для від учителів очікується теж велика
робота і так само як від
учнів чим менш структурована робота тим
більше викликів це створює для учителя
учитель має успішно
самоорганізовуватися тепер поговоримо
про другу амбіцію а саме структуроване
поглиблення навичок учні
йдуть з класу в клас з 10 в 11 12й це
дозволяє їм глибше пізнати той чи інший
предмет і це мене вже призводить до
важелю п'ять
ви використовуєте додатковий рік для
того
щоб дозволити учням спробувати різні
шляхи є обов'язкові навички в предметах
таких я українська або
математика можна
також ускладнювати деякі
предмети можна подумати
це Що це можливо для іноземних мов
біології хімії фізики хімії там можливі
різні комбінації там можуть бути також
звичайно на історія фізичне виховання
особистий розвиток це теж може бути
обов'язково і
можна їх комбінувати з іншими галузями
так ось візьму цей 10й
Клас Я б не хотів щоб Ви думали що
просто додали 12-й Клас Ні насправді
додали 10й клас тому що це Точка входу в
старшу школу саме під час цього року
можна дослідити можливості щось нове
спробувати цей рік учні почнуть вже
орієнтуватися і зрозуміють які
можливості їм
надаються колись в своєму житті учень
з'ясує Що наприклад щось йому вже не
цікаво на що він націлювався з 10того
класу і тісно під час 10-го класу учні
отримують простір для
маневрів тепер Давайте поговоримо про
спеціалізацію в 10-му і 12-му
класах в 11му12му класах тут можна
зробити
вибір можна вчити загально математику і
вирішувати чи вивчати статистику
прикладну математику знову таки те саме
стосує це мови мову можна вчати
поглиблено і літературу також це той
момент в який ви починаєте поліпшувати
або же поглиблювати наявні вже навички і
є також опції пов'язані з профілем Я
вважаю що це теж дуже важливо наприклад
фізика хімія
ча
математика
тут Можуть бути різні курси при
математично-протичні науки гуманітарні
науки і подумайте про 11-й і 12-й клас
як той етап коли учні починають
спеціалізуватися коли вони починають
поглиблювати те що вони здобили в 10-му
ну і з рештою амбіція номер три як ми
можемо зміцнити Містки між світом
навчання і рештою світу як також учні
можуть зробити соціальний внесок ми
бачимо що кар'єрні очікування молодих
людей не зовсім узгоджуються між собою
ви бачите це На
графіку
часом Учні не мають достатнього уявлень
того як в реальному світі будуть
використовуватися їхні
навички один з
10ти
українців не планує йти у вищого світу є
розумні учні за результатами Піз але
вони не уявляють поки що подальшої
освіти для себе як же ми можемо
допомогти здібним молодим людям
зрозуміти які перед ними відкриваються
можливості і
варіанти можна провести наприклад
спеціальний курс
з особистісного розвитку це може бути
також
профорієнтування Що дозволить відкрити
можливості в світі освіти в світі роботи
це може бути особистий план
і за допомогою цього учні отримують
краще бачення кар'єрних можливостей
сгодні багато способів віртуальні
інтернатури стажування
наприклад можна Таким чином Побачити які
різні можливості роботи у роботодавця і
Можна інтегрувати ці варіанти це не буде
відбирати час від основного навчання і
учні побачать наприклад що ось саме цим
я ми хотіли би зайнятися в своєму житті
Ну і зрештою учням необхідно надати
полегшений доступ до сучасної
інформації про наявні можливості прац
влаштування не треба
недооцінювати труднощі цього процесу
учні знають свою школу знають ким
працюють батьки але їм не просто
зрозуміти що їм запропонує майбутнє
Особливо якщо вони проживають в
сільській місцевості де можливості
працевлаштування можуть бути досить
обмежені знов таки молоді Треба надати
хорошу інформацію про те що лежить за
межами
школи що вони будуть заробляти які
можливості для розвитку кар'єри
Я думаю що це те що я хотів поділитися з
вами Ось маємо
резюме дев'ять напрямків три амбіції які
ви можете впливати допомагати учням
зміснювати свій
талант рекомендувати де вони можуть
зробити свій
внесок опрацювати свої
навички і створити гарну обізнаність
стосовно того що ж буде світ пропонувати
молоді дякує щиро колеги в зв'язку з
щільним графіком Я думаю питання ми
поставимо вже в індивідуальному
приватному порядку шановним доповідачам
нашим
Дякую Ви можете займати місця в залі and
you А я з особливо трепетним моментом
після отакого широкого теоретичного
контексту і ґрунтовної ґрунтовного
аналізу від наших доповідачів особливо
трепетно хочу запросити сюди свою до
слова свою співмодераторку
а академічну радницю організації
економічної співпраці та розвитку
першого проректора Київського
університету імені Бориса Грінченка
міністра освіти і науки України у
2016-19 роках пані Лілю михайлівну
Гринев
[оплески]
Дуже дякую Ігорю Григоровичу Шановні
колеги Ну мені здається що ця
презентація яку Ми щойно почули вже дала
нам дуже широкий широке поле
думок про те яким чином ми будемо
рухатися далі з реформою І звісно мені
особливо приємно що Зараз ми не зважаючи
А скоріше всього зважаючи на всі нові
виклики у порівнянні з
2017 чи 18 роком які є у нашій країні
рухаємося вперед і рухаємося вперед
залучивши
ее направду скажу вам найкращу
експертизу міжнародну яка зараз сьогодні
може бути
доступною ще раз Щиро дякуємо вам пане
андреасе за те що ви уможливили сьогодні
на цей майданчик в Україні привести
експертів з п'яти країн Це будуть колеги
і високопосадовці тобто ті хто творять
освітню політику це також будуть
керівники закладів освіти які
безпосередньо творять цей простір
старшої профільної школи і є найкращими
в своїй справі І я хотів хотіла б
сказати про деякі технічні
питання Ясно що в наших презентерів
можуть бути певні графіки яких Вам може
бути не видно на цих екранах тому кожна
презентація буде підвантажена за
qr-кодом у
вас і ви зможете до всього
придивитися друге що ще є дуже
важливо у нас будуть спеціальні
поглиблені сесії інтерв'ю зі спікерами
тобто то ми зараз прослухаємо
презентації будь ласка нотуйте ваші
запитання тому що на поглиблених сесіях
інтерв'ю ми зможемо про все розпитати і
ще третій інсайт ее оця візія про яку
сьогодні е розповідав пан Андреас
шляйхер також узагальнена в
концептуальному документі я який ви
зможете отримати наприкінці першого дня
і в якому будуть зафіксовані певні
позиції з найкращого міжнародного
досвіду наше з вами завдання додати туди
український контекст і всі наші
напрацювання будуть також включені в цю
концепцію А зараз для першої сесії в
якій візьмуть участь наші колеги з
Естонії
та
Німеччини будь ласка я надаю слово пану
Ігорю дякую щиро колеги Отже ще раз
нагадаю qr-код про який сказала Лілія
Михайлівна на зворотному боці вашого
реєстраційного бейджа туди наприкінці
дня буде довантажено і візійний документ
Андреаса і всі презентації які ви
сьогодні бачитимете Отже я коротко
представлю наших
доповідачівдоповідачок цемі
Міністерство освіти та досліджень та
колишній керівник
школи в Ян гімназumм
Естонія улі тепер працює координатором
створення державних гімназій державному
шкільному департаменті міносвіти та
досліджень також улі багато Ів років
працювала керівником школи керівником
школи в гімназії в іванді в Естонії в
2011 улі маціін створила першу державну
гімназію в Естонії і Взяла на себе роль
керівника до 2020 року і під її
керівництвом гімназія стала взірцем
освітньої досконалості під час зустрічі
улі буде розповідати старшу середню
освіту з точки зору міністерства та та
Як колишній керівник
школи наш наступний
учасник пані речел Марі пердільє
деваль
керівник навчання
в із Франції вона
є є також керівником озброєнь вранці
полковника перейшла в Міністерство
освітиі
2021 року як керівник Департаменту
державного навчання і педагогічної дії
вона розповість про свій досвід серії
інженерної справи та механіки у
військовій школі також розповість про
Міністерство освіти в 2020 році де вона
відповідала за ключові стратегії та
життя
студентів також пані донік
жевель
приєднався до ліцею шар
деголь влітку 2022 року він очолював
французькі ліцеї в Іспанії та ливані
також в різних регіонах Франції Мені
дуже приємно передати слово надати слово
першому
доповідачу панові пані улі матсн з
Естонії будь ласка вимкніть слайди
Дуже дякую за цю можливість розповісти
про естонський досвід в
галузі вищої середньої освіти старшої
середньої освіти Ми скріз шукаємо
найкращі практики і ми можемо бачити що
всі ті виклики які ми бачимо в Європі
можуть бути корисними для того щоб
побудувати освітню
систему яка буде найкраще підходити для
вашого
суспільства
Отже я би хотіла розпочати свої
[музика]
пояснення коли ми будемо переглядати
слайди наступний
слайд Ви можете
бачити що в нас є в Естонії
досить невелике населення це означає що
1,3
мльни 1,3 мльона населення і ми добилися
змін досить
швидко я покажу вам скільки ж шкіл в нас
є це означає що в Естонії в
Естонії
ми знаємо насправді всіх директорів шкіл
Міністерство на всіх директорів шкіл по
країні там трохи є
Ехо це якось
впливає Ехо немає просто Ми чекали поки
вимкнуть
слайди
Отже ми невеличка країна з невеличким
населенням це означає що ми можемо
охопити всі школи досить швидко
і вирішити всі ці проблеми
оскільки це все дуже близько
2021 року в нас було прийнято план
загальної освіти відповідно до цього
плану Ми плануємо всю політику в галузі
осві в Естонії
Отже йдеться про основні завдання
основні цілі в сфері
освіти тут можна бачити завдання освіти
[музика]
Естонії в нас є блок базової освіти це
обов'язкова освіта після обов'язкової
освіти яка є базової освіти вже йде
старша середня освіта
[музика]
ми
маємо
155 вищих середніх шкіл старших середніх
шкіл в Естонії що пропонують загальну
освіту також в нас є професійно технічні
училища і також для тих осіб що
досягають вищої старшої середньо освіти
35 є ПТУ для тих учнів які хочуть
продовжити
своє навчання в професійно-технічній
школі
сьогодні в нас є така можливість в
Естонії ми знаходимося в такій ситуації
що населення зменшується і виникає дуже
велика дискусія в Естонії Скільки ж
старших середніх шкіл нам потрібно для
того щоб
запропонувати всі
можливості повну навчальну програму і
повна кваліфікаційну програму і
забезпечити
якість старшої середньої освіти оскільки
саме якість це важливе тема для Естонії
сьогодні з 2011 року ми
впровадили окремий державний план
навчання для старшої середньої школи і з
того
моменту вже в нас виникла система
коли старша середня школа вже має
1/трети усіх усього навчального
плану можуть вони вирішувати самостійно
дані школи отже як вже про це
йшлося в попередній
доповіді що так в Естонії є обов'язкова
частина навчальної програми крім того
можна обирати ще додаткову частину
відповідно до інтересів
до власних інтересів все ще в нас існує
дискусія стосовно того чи потрібно нам
більше інтегрованого способу для того
щоб всі предмети були в державному
навчальному плані Сьогодні ми
впроваджуємо цей вже наступну версію
державного її
програми для
шкіл для того щоб інтегрувати до купи
різні предмети і щоб запланувати
навчання відповідно до
результатів так все ще Ми рахуємо уроки
але ми переходимо все більше і
більше до такої системи де Ми
визначаємо Уже результати на державному
рівні І кожна школа буде приймати
навчальний план на рівні
школи в
Естонії на досить велика автономія для
кожної школи вона може приймати
навчальний план самостійно і
1/3 навчального
плану може створюватися абсолютно вільно
відповідно до потреб та відповідно до
побажань учнів у
школі це дозволяє об'єднувати предмети і
наприклад
навчати наука науку не відокремлювати не
фізику не біологію не хімію вчити при
цьому А можливо навчати взагалі науку
загалом і давати можливість
учням обирати додаткові курси наприклад
хімії або фізики або біології відповідно
до їхніх
[музика]
інтересів сьогодні великий виклик в
Естонії як я вже сказала раніше
це кількість старших середніх шкіл Як ви
побачите на наступному
слайді Як ви побачите на наступному
слайді зменшується населення в різних
регіонах
Естонії за
винятком столиці таліна там п
3% але в основному зменшується кількість
учнів і тому важливо
проаналізувати мережу наших середніх
шкіл і тут в нас
є план щоб створити нове
законодавство на наступні с років Ми
хотіли би
[музика]
досягти прийняття нового законодавства
про старшу середню школу в такий спо
щоб ми не використовували вже цієї
інституційної системи А в нас була
загальна освіта і
професійно-технічна освіта на старшій
середній школі запровадити це в таким
чином щоб Кожен учень який приходить на
обов'язкову середню освіту міг би
обирати навчальний план відповідно до
своїх
інтересів і якась
тут буде з професійно-технічної школи
якась буде частина з навчального плану
загальноосвітньої школи Отже ми будемо
впроваджувати персональний план навчання
це для нас сьогодні великий виклик і
відповідно до цього ми обговорюємо
сьогодні в
[музика]
Естонії збільшення віку обов'язкової
школи на один рік і
впровадити вже цю систему починаючи з
наступного
року щоб Кожен учень після базової
освіти Повинен був би обирати вже
наступний шлях на рівні старшої
середньої школи це може бути
загальноосвітня школа може може бути
професійно технічна школа і вони
пропонують ці навчальні плани спільно це
буде змішаний навчальний план і буде
індивідуальний підхід не буде
інституційного підходу
Отже це є
гнучкість яка нам потрібна для такого
невеликого населення після того як ми
проаналізували нашу шкільну
систему на наступному слайді Я хотіла би
розповісти про деякі характеристики щодо
нашої старшої середньої освіти і ви
можете на екрані вивести всі ці пункти і
буде простіше для слухачів
[музика]
якщо ви вже виведете всі пункти то я
почну їх пояснювати також
спільно їх лише
чотири а я почну з
першого сьогодні
вища старша середня школа не є
обов'язкова як я вже сказала ви хотіли
би впровадити законодавство щоб
підвищити
вік обов'язкової школи на один рік Отже
Кожний учень після базової освіти буде
обирати подальше навчання після базової
освіти
Сьогодні ми бачимо що 70% наших учнів
обирають загальну
освіту 30% обирають професійно
технічного
освіту ви тут
бачите який виклик для Естонії коли ми
проваджуємо цей новий шкільний вік щодо
обов'язкової школи то нам
потрібно підвищити кількість учнів які
будуть обирати професійні технічний
модуль або навчальний
план в
рамках старшої середньої освіти тому що
ми бачимо що на ринку праці
необхідно мати рівень старшої середньої
освіти і це означає що сьогодні
суспільству
потрібні потрібно від наших учнів гарні
навички в
рамках загальної середньої освіти і
також готовність працювати готовність до
ринку
праці ми
зацікавлені розвивати нашу освітню
систему на рівні старшої середньої школи
в такий спосіб щоб кожний учень міг
обирати компетенції які йому потрібні
які будуть буде він
використовувати він або Вона для того
щоб рухатися далі це може бути
орієнтація на
Університет може бути більша орієнтація
на ринок праці Отже необхідна гнучкість
Ми повинні бути
гнучкими ми повинні також приймати
рішення
стосовно року початку навчання і
стосовно того який навчальний план буде
обрано це означає що ми хочемо
персоналізувати менш
інституціоналізувати А більш
персоналізувати
є трирічний навчальний план в
професійно-технічній школі пропонується
триваліший навчальний план і це означає
що також можна обрати чотири роки і оці
цей чотирирічний навчальний план може
бути впроваджений в
майбутньому коли
учні які
вже
не зможуть вирішити після базової освіти
де їм навчатися далі Отже нам
знадобиться півроку або рік навчального
плану для того щоб розвивати загальні
компетенції планування кар'єри і таке
інше старша середня освіта
це для тих учнів які їх хотіли би
продовжити навчання в університеті тут є
певні причини цього твердження чому ж 7
в наших учнів
[музика]
обирають загальну середню освіту Важливо
При
цьому також підвищувати популярність
професійної-технічної
освіти тому що нам
потрібно навчати їх в професійні
технічній школі Отже нам треба
впроваджувати інтегрований навчальний
план в загальній і професійно-технічній
школі це підвищить інтерес учнів до того
щоб вибирати саме навчальний план
професійно-технічної школи на рівні
вищої середньої школи для нас
важливо
пропонувати
кваліфікацію Та той навчальний план
якого потребує Кожний учень для того щоб
бути успішним на ринку
праці
для то або для того щоб планувати
подальше навчання в університеті і Дана
гнучкість дасть можливість обрати
навчальний план відповідно до потреб або
завдань або
побажань на наступному
слайді є коротка характеристика щодо
нашої професійно-технічної
школи на наступному слайді ви можете
побачити
про професійну технічну освіту вона
безплатна вже вона
безкоштовна в законодавстві є два типи
законодавства Для загальної освіти друге
законодавство про професійно-технічну
освіту і ми побачимо що більше гнучкості
якраз і більше орієнтації на ринок праці
саме в законодавстві про
професійно-технічну освіту і звичайно ж
ми хотіли б досягти такої ж стратегії і
в законодавстві що стосується загальної
середньої
освіти але це дуже важливо для
професійно-технічної
освіти що вони вже привели зміст у
відповідність до ринку
праці і кожна школа має шкільну Раду в
яку входять також представники
приватного сектору
також від регіонів Отже вони приймають
рішення щодо навчального плану в такий
спосіб щоб представники приватного
сектору також ці всі побажання
приватного сектору та також регіональної
влади будуть враховуватися під час
визначення навчального
плану і нарешті я хотіла би
вказати на наші цілі щодо
освіти стратегію 2035 року це на
наступному
слайді і ви побачите
що загальна мета така
що естонці мали
знання навички та відношення Які би
допомагали в самореалізації в особистому
житті роботи для блага суспільства і для
того щоби підвищувати якість життя в
Естонії є тут три таких цілі перша Мета
- це розмаїття цілей
навчання
доступність
доступність освіти друге - це навчання
протягом життя створення
можливостей навчання протягом життя
згідно потреб ринку праці і Третє
це є гарна орієнтація щоб учні саме
гарно зорієнтувалися для того щоб
добитися успіху в професійному життя всі
ці три
цілі включені до нашої
стратегії в рамках політики
освіти яку ми
розробляємо і ми рухаємося до
персоналізованої
освіти щоб Кожен учень міг
обирати собі освіту відповідно до цілей
та для того щоб добитися успіху в житті
та на ринку праці Дуже дякую шановні
учасники звичайно ж ми продовжимо
подальшу дискусію стосовно
освіти Дуже
дякую Отже ми рухаємося
далі до нашого наступного
доповідача пані рейчель Марі
вона тут є в онлайн знаходиться в нас
буде
переклад Ми дуже вас вітаємо
[музика]
тепло
Дуже дякую перепрошую за проблеми з
перекладом Отже перш за все хочу
розказати вам про
навчання для того щоб представити вам як
відбувається навчання в наших школах
після третьго класу з учнями яким 15
років які починають вчитися у ліцеї які
вступають які обирають Один із трьох
шляхів якими вони будуть іти аж до
можливості продовжити вищу освіту це
професійно-технічна освіта метою якої є
одразу перейти до
професійно-тхчної діяльності сепи і або
ж вони можуть вчитися два роки для того
щоб отримати атестат про
середньютехнічну освіту і
це після того як Вони отримають цей
атестат вони також зможуть продовжити
вищу
освіту і також є технологічний шлях І
загальний шлях це навчання яке
відбувається у ліцеї і воно допомагає
підготувати учнів до вступу у вищий
навчальний заклад загального
плану метою є отримати
або ступінь магістра або продов
освіту після закінчення
цього терміну для того щоб далі
продовжити наприклад вчитися на медицині
чи інших факультетах що стосується цього
технологічного шляху то він стосується
учнів які хочуть вчитися наприклад в
галузі
санітарно-соціальній
сільськогосподарській чи інших
професійних сферах далі для того щоб
отримати ступінь бакалавра чи
магістра і але це освіта яка триває
трошки менше ніж загальна освіта ніж
загальна вища освіта для того
щоб обрати один із цих
[музика]
шляхів загальна та
загальнотехногічний напрямок об'єднують
студентів у Франції і мета цього всього
досягти прогресу і вивчити ті елементи
про які уже йшлося сьогодні зранку
для того щоб зрозуміти яким чином
супроводжувати цих учнів від 15-18 років
для того щоб допомогти їм зробити свій
вибір і допомогти навчатися і
розвиватися і це те чого відбувається у
нас останнім часом
Отже я хочу повернутися до того факту що
ця реформа яка розпочалася у 2017 році
яка розпочалася із з почала втілюватися
із початку навчального року 2019 року і
його мета - це знайти баланс між
прозорістю освіти для того щоб я
сподіваюся що презентацію добре видно
так тому
що один слайд здається ми перескочили
один
слайд Добре я буду продовжувати а потім
ми повернемося до попереднього слайду
Отже мета у 2017 році
баланс гармонії між загальною
освітою Яку мають проходити усі
учні що допоможе їм пізніше вступити до
вищого навчального закладу і також це
допомагає їм отримати спеціалізацію і
обрати Шлях який буде більше їх
мотивувати тому що таким чином вони
зможуть краще вчитися і це також
можливість
обрати можливість одночасно
підготуватися до
вступу у ВУЗ і також
отримати отримати професійну
освіту для того щоб Цей підхід був
збалансований щоб вони могли дізнаватися
достатньо про загально про загальну
культуру Про науку та інші сфери і також
продовжувати розвиватися в цьому
напрямку і також Як ви
бачите на слайді ді усе це
представлено під час другого курсу
навчання такого навчання це обов'язкове
навчання і є два
варіанти Я хочу якраз розказати вам про
ці два
варіанти від молодого віку дуже важливо
супроводжувати учнів якщо у них
виникають якісь проблеми чи складнощі і
зокрема допомагати їм обрати свій
просіний шлях зокрема під час на
навчання Коли вони зокрема можуть
приймати рішення продовжити навчання за
кордоном чи в одному з регіонів Франції
почати вчити мистецтво чи культуру попри
все
можливості зробити вплив У рамках
навчання в їхньому ліцеї для того щоб
продовжити навчання у вищому навчальному
закладі Це ті компетенції які
допомагають їм зорієнтуватися і це
насправді не просто це вимагає зрілості
саме тому протягом трьох років навчання
в загальному та технологічному
ліцеї Ми допомагаємо цим учням і є 54
години присвячені наставництву це
зустрічі із фахівцями із вчителями та
викладачами вищих навчальних закладів
які допомагають учням визначитися що
вони хочуть робити тому що вони все ще
дуже молоді Можливо вони ще не
визначилися і їм потрібно зрозуміти що
робити після отримання атестату про
середню
освіту це те що відбувається на етапі
середньої освіти і вони також повинні
зрозуміти яким чином їхнє навчання може
перейти до вищої освіти це допомагає їм
зробити перший вибір тому що У рамках У
рамках цього першого року
навчання учні яким від 15 до 16 років
повинні обрати три спеціалізованих
напрямки які будуть
відповідати
їхньому подальшому навчанні відповідно
від цього вони будуть знати чим Чим
займатися Це на вибір
учнів у них є розмаїття є можливість
вибору також є додаткові предмети
необов'язкові предмети і також у кожного
учня є спеціалізований напрямок освіти
який відповідатиме їхнім академічним
запитам для того щоб вони могли краще
обрати свою орієнтацію вибрати той
напрямок навчання який їм
підходить І
це та ідея яка допомагає нам
супроводжувати учнів аж до отримання
атестату і далі до продовження вищої
освіти
далі ми переходимо до випускного курсу
учні можуть опрагати дві
спеціальності в останньому класі
це два основних напрямки дві основних
спеціальності і вони
також мають можливість поглибити свої
знання у цих спеціальностях для того щоб
справді отримати більше знань більше
навичок конкретно у цьому напрямку які
допоможуть їм перейти далі до вищої
освіти між першим роком навчання в
ліцеї і між і до випускного
класу стає все більше спеціалізовани
спеціалізованих предметів тому що учні
роблять більш конкретний вибір і вони
продовжують
навчатися для того щоб обрати свій шлях
обрати спеціальність для вищої освіти і
покращити той вибір який вони
зробили і в цьому є мета середньої
освіти для того щоб учні могли як
найкраще використовувати свою жливості і
обрати свій напрямок
навчання поглянемо як це виглядає
особливо під час другого року навчання
наступний слайд будь
ласка
Отже
26 годин навчання кожного тижня
мета цього року навчання допомогти усім
учням
зрештою обрати
спеціальність я про це розкажу трошки
пізніше Отже мета обрати цей напрямок
навчання і
Зрештою вони можуть обрати або
гуманітарні
спеціальності це
те навчання У рамках якого вони також
отримують загальну освіту чи освіту у
загальних
предметах Це допоможе їм обрати свою
професійну діяльність і окрім того Вони
можуть також обрати додаткові предмети
які допоможуть їм
або обрати додаткові предмети які будуть
підходити конкретно їм це може бути
можуть бути якісь мистецькі предмети або
ж це може бути
фізкультура або це можуть бути модулі
пов'язані із іншими предметами і з тими
які
є обов'язковими У рамках загальної
освіти і далі та також учні можуть
обрати додатково технологічного світу
технологічні предмети для того щоб
спробувати
себе чи зможуть
вони продовжити навчання у цьому
напрямку і чи можуть вони досягти своїх
цілей які стосуються наприклад навчання
на дизайні чи на інженерних
спеціальностях чи в секторі надання
послуг наприклад або ж в
санітарно-соціальному напрямку
такий вибір допомагає їм розробити
знання і навички і також розпочати
міркувати над тим чим вони можуть
займатися після закінчення ліцею тому що
у випускному класі тому що на додачу
до тако
таких годин навчання коли воно може
зустрічатися із наставниками на
наступній сторінці ви побачите яким
чином виглядає
перший рік навчання у
ліцеї тобто завжди є загальне ядро
загальний принцип який однаковий для
усіх учнів але на додачу до цього
основного ядра є
також
два два напрямки спеціального навчання
які допомагають учням підготуватися до
вищої
освіти є три таких напрямки
спеціальності вони зможуть продовжувати
у випускному
класі але обрати Вони мають у перший
рік від тих до 6 годин Це
спеціалізація яка допомагає їм обрати із
широкої низки
предметів зараз є вісім спеціальностей
які систематично пропонується
учням і
зокрема
є 10 спеціальностей які
пропонуються пропонуються учням ліцею
вони зможуть визначитися трошки пізніше
учні
які також можуть вчити додаткові
предмети і
продовжувати вчитися більш
персоналізовано для того щоб обрати
предмети які цікавлять конкретно
[музика]
їх і мати програ навчання яка як
найкраще адаптується до їхніх потреб на
додачу до загальних предметів вони
можуть обрати предмети за вибором
залежно від їхньої мотивації вони
також можуть
обрати якщо вони можуть операти то це
робить їх більш мотивованими Звісно ж і
це також важливий фактор який допомагає
їм визначитися розрізнити різних учнів
для того щоб вони як найкраще змогли
брати свій подальший шлях у вищій освіті
якщо ми поглянемо на процес вибору це те
що ви можете побачити На наступному
слайді є дуже важливий
елемент якщо ми говоримо про різницю між
різними соціально-професійними
категоріями про можливості супроводу
учнів то дуже важливо супроводжувати їх
саме на етапі середньої освіти для того
щоб ті у яких Поки що немає можливостей
наприклад мати достатньо підтримки з
інших з інших сфер вони
могли краще розуміти чого вони хочуть
зрозуміти що вони хочуть вивчати після
закінчення ліцею для того щоб у всіх був
рідний доступ до освіти щоб у всіх були
рівні
шанси це дуже важливо тому щоі
після після п'ятого року навчання тобто
попередні це на попередньому етапі Учні
повинні визначитися над вибором
майбутнього навчання це такий
підхід яким керує або якийсь окремо
обраний вчитель і на додачі також є
психолог який працює із учнями для того
щоб допомогти їм на основі їхніх
компетенцій обрати свій напрямок
навчання це також може бути навчання яка
якнайкраще підходить конкретному
обраному
напрямку і з допомогою таких вчителів
таких викладачів
Протягом цього Протягом цього часу учні
можуть зрозуміти яких компетенцій міх
бракує для того щоб продовжувати
навчатися на цьому
напрямку сьогодні учні можуть одночасно
здобувати кілька спеціальностей У рамках
такої професійної
освіти і вони також мають
можливість
розвиватися еволюціонувати У рамках
цього підходу це дуже
важливо щоб вони мали можливості
спілкуватися з фахівцями які пропонують
їм різні варіанти для того щоб ці
фахівці могли показати їм яким чином
вони змінили яким чином можна змінити ці
на ці обрані спеціальності для того щоб
учні дійсно
могли найкраще використати свій
потенціал для того щоб вони дійсно
розуміли що відбувається в реальності і
як відбуватиметься вищ освіта для того
щоб учні могли зрозуміти як
відбуватиметься цей процес конкретно для
них Якщо ми
поглянемо на те як відбувається
викладання в першому від першого та до
останнього класу навчання в ліцеї То як
ви бачите тут
є загальна кількість навчання годин на
тиждень від 16 до 17,5 годин протягом
першого року навчання 15,5 протягом
останнього року
навчання
і далі ще додається кілька годин
навчання для того щоб учні могли вивчати
ці
спеціальності тобто є частина предметів
які вивчають усі учні це на приклад
французька
філософія сучасні мови Тобто це загальні
гуманітарні дисципліни також є моральний
громадянське виховання історія та
географія і також природничі науки які
мають вивчати усі учні до реформи це
було трошки не так мета цієї реформи
полягає у тому щоб усі учні одночасно
мали достатньо знань і в науках і в
природничих науках і в гуманітарних
науках незалежно від того чим вони
оберуть займати після закінчення
ліцею що стосується спеціальної освіти
то Тут також є широкий спектр предметів
і ви зможете побачити у детальніше це на
наступному
[музика]
слайді водночас учні тут отримують
навчання із гуманітарних наук із
соціальних наук також вони
вивчають мистецькі предмети вони
вивчають предмети стосуються культури
мов вивчають класичні мови античні мови
або ж сучасні мови іноземні мови чи
регіональні
мови
також є
предмети
географія геополітика історія також
економічні та соціальні науки
це те також що змінилося після реформи
також є
предмети які стосуються наукової та
технологічної культури це можуть бути
математика фізика хімія природничі науки
і також цифрові науки інформатика або
інженерні
предмети також є два предмети
які які чим далі стають більш
популярними це зокрема фізична культура
та біологія
екологія загал цих
меті не представлений у всіх
ліцеях окрім окрім хіба що мистецтва всі
ці інші предмети присутні у
більшості ліцеїв від шести до девти
напрямків у кожному ліцеї і тому учні
дійсно можуть
обрати знизки цих предметів те що
цікавить їх уе залежить від вибору
конкретного учня звісно вони можуть
користуватися порадами їхніх вчителів
які підкажуть
їм до чого у них лежить душа І в чому
вони можуть досягти найбільшого успіху і
таким чином учні можуть правильно
здобути середню освіту для того щоб далі
продовжити
навчання після закінчення ліцею що
стосується факультативних курсів то
ситуація
така ці факультативні курси також
допомагають учням вибрати низки
дисциплін те що їм допомагає для того
щоб вони
могли обрати те що доповнюватиме їхню
загальну освіту
це факультативні курси між різними
дисциплінами мета цієї реформи
це мотивувати
учнів підсилити їхній вибір для того щоб
вони могли
якнайкраще пропрацювати ті спеціальності
які вони обрали
Але знову ж таки усе залежить від вибору
учня до реформи було
багато учнів які обирали наукові
дисципліни більш як 60% учнів обирали
цей напрямок далі від 25 до 30 учнів
обирали економічні науки і решта учнів
обирали
більш більш літературний напрямок
навчання на наступному слайді ви зможете
побачити що переважна
більшість таких дисциплін добре
збалансована крок за кроком навіть якщо
протягом першого року навчання в
ліцеї учні обирають певний напрямок
навчання якщо ми поглянемо на те що
відбувається
сьогодні найпопулярніших спеціальностей
це математика економічно економічні та
соціальні науки фізика хімія природнича
наука та історія і географія геополітика
та політичні
студії що
стосується що
стосується інформації на цьому слайді то
ми бачимо певний баланс між цими
дисциплінами тому що приблизно третина
учнів
обирає під час з першого та
останнього років навчання
в ліцеї саме наукової дисципліни далі
третина обирають економічні науки та
гуманітарні науки і третина
учнів що стосується їхнього вибору то
вони обирають або гуманітарні науки або
економічні науки або мистецький напрямок
навчання і зрештою це приводить до
дійсно Великого різноманіття
спеціальностей і це саме те що було
підкреслено У
рамках реформи
освіти починаючи з 2019
року зараз учні мають можливість в повні
скористатися своїм
вибором хоча це не просто Але такий
відкритий вибір Значно краще
працює
і він значно важливіший набуває значно
більшого значення ніж раніше тому що
учні дійсно
можуть
обирати те що вони хочуть навчати і
відповідно поповнювати ці знання
Протягом навчання в ліцеї Що стосується
випускного класу
то тут також учні
можуть
розширити ті предмети які вони
вивчають є багато учнів які
обирають математику біологію хімію
фізику та хімію але чим далі більше є
учнів які обирають більш різноманітні
предмети протягом протягом нав після
трьох років після того як ця реформа
була прийнята Якщо ви
поглянете на цей баланс між
різноманітними предметами і дисциплінами
то У рамках реформи однією із цілей була
також
Дати Дати учням можливість отримати цей
атестат таким чином що вони далі
продовжили вищу освіту у напрямку який
вони
обрали для того щоб вони змогли здати
іспити зрештою після того як реформа
була прийнята як і в багатьох інших
країнах
реформа цього атестата про середню
освіту бере до
уваги постійний контроль за знаннями
Тобто це постійні тести постійні іспити
які відбуваються під час першого та
останнього року навчання і
допомагають учням зрозуміти отримати
атестат і далі продовжити навчання уже У
рамках вищої освіти є п'ять іспитів під
час останнього року навчання це іспити
французької філософії та спеціальностей
спеціальних дисциплін які учні вивчали
під час третього року навчання у
ліцеї є також певні інновації які
допомагають учням підсилити свої знання
у цих напрямках і Далі розвиватися
протягом усього
життя це компетенції
це перевірка учнів висловлюватися для
того щоб перевірити наскільки вони
можуть захищати свою точку зору
висловлюватися вони мають
продемонструвати що вони можуть
виступати що вони можуть захищати свої
переконання можуть захищати свої ідеї
це те що важливо для кожного учня
незалежно від того де він продовжуватиме
вчитися на додачу до
цього на додачу до реформи навчання в
ліцеї та до реформи цього атестату про
середню вищу освіту дуже важливо також
працювати із учнями та з їхніми родинами
і наму у мене майже все але я хочу також
розказати вам про ще один важливий
елемент це проект оцінки проект який
також був введений в рамках
реформи
якщо якщо ми хочемо полегшити життя
учням дуже важливо щоб усі вчителі
розуміли як відбувається це оцінювання
знань учнів
[музика]
тому що вони будуть супроводжувати учнів
під час їхньої освіти і далі заклади
вищої освіти які приймуть на навчання ци
студентів також матимуть змогу зрозуміти
як з ними
[музика]
працювати дуже важливо
щоб учні добре розуміли у чому полягають
виклики цього оцінювання що саме
оцінюється які тести і іспити
проводяться адже це навчання адже це оці
проводиться У різних форматах протягом
їхньої освіти для того щоб учні могли
перевірити свої знання які допоможуть їм
продовжувати вищу освіту і перейти від
статусу учня до абітурієнта і далі до
студента Таким чином в рамках реформи
Нам вдалося зробити зміни які
допомагають краще зрозуміти компетенції
учнів звісно на це потрібно був час і до
речі ця реформа
приймалася впроваджувалася під час
пандемії що дуже вплинуло на увести
процес але в будь-якому разі ця реформа
позитивна тому що вона допомагає учням
зробити вибір але вона також накладає на
них певні зобов'язання тому що їхні роки
навчання у ліцеї - це їхня можливість
обрати свою спеціальність і подальший
напрямок
освіти Жаль дуже щільний графік якщо ви
не заперечите будемо рухатися далі Дуже
дякую Дуже дякую за цю
презентацію ще один
виступ Містер Домінік жавель ми маємо
відеозапис пана
Домініка прошу вивести його на
екран
Доброго дня
всім На жаль я дистанційно працюю але на
жаль мої професійні обов'язки не не
дозволили мені працювати напряму тобто я
я вам декілька елементів нада надам
стосовно того про що ми
будемо тут
говорити Я я працюю в ліцеї Шарля деголя
в діжоні і
це ліцей загальної освітній і
технологічний він перебу Він
розташований на півночі міста діжон і в
ньому
1060 учнів 12
класів від 16
років 10 перого
і
девять випускних класів
насамперед це
такий
секторальне навчання у нас три коледжі в
секторі і учні учні досить складні і і
там
60%
складають складні учні і
потім
ми набираємо із різних
секторів це
стосується
бак міжнародного
бакалавревата Британській системмі і
також є відділення
франко-німецьке Вони
отримують на випускному класі бакалаврат
як французький так і німецький
То тобто це
готуються учні студенти для для спе
спеціалізація не не не не мови а
математики фізика
хімія але але іноземними мовами і також
є декілька опці
опційних варіантів які нам
дозволяють працювати з учнями які
приїхали з да
то учні частково
вибирають основну
частину і у на у нашому ліцеї Таким
чином працюють
декілька іноземці Навіть є українці і це
іноземці Які іноземні учні які
навчаються десь місяцьтри місяці і
більше і які які працюють по французькій
програмі
тобто яка дуже диверсифікована і
також
ми на першому
уроці
учні
займаються спеціалізованим
навчанням і
пошістьшість
годин математика
фізика класичні
науки історія географія які потрібні для
бакалаврата тобто є
підрозділ мов тобто англійська мова
вивчають і що важливо
підкреслити
це давні мови такі як грецька та латина
а також є спеціалізовання мистецтво і
танець інш інша важлива пункт який
потрібно відзначити яким чином ми
працюємо французька система - це
одночастово і і розклад і програми які
на національному рівні
визначаються тобто досить така
централізована система але
Але у вчителів у викладачів є
достатньо достатньо простір для
маневру вони можуть
наприклад це стосується особливо
економічних і політичних наук вони
можуть
працювати разом з асоціаціями
які
займаються в
цьому у цій
області тобто тобто більш-менш часу
могуть уділяти цим опційним
наукам
основа на національного національної
освіти То тобто і тут тут не не можна
дискутувати тому що це обов'язково А
але можна можна
конкретно конкретно використовувати
застосовувати Т ті чи інші підходи тобто
кожний заклад навчальний він він ставить
перед собою питання що ми хочемо
отримати для нашого для нашого закладу
освіти тобто от на наприклад Наш ліцей
Шарля деголя ми чим ми відрізняємось від
інших ліцеїв яку орієнтацію
ми виберемо Який сенс Ми надамо от наш
нашій нашому навчанню що ми виберемо для
наших
учнів і і із цього випливає декілька
пунктів перший перши пункт -
це
глобалізація тобто тобто Ми займаємося
ВС
всією
ю шкільною спільнотою щоб було
доброзичлива
атмосфера щоб була професійне
відношення
персоналу нашого ліцею це це перша така
на напрям а потім супровід друге це
супровід учнів тобто інколи учні
прибувають вони трошки методів не знають
наших Тобто їх потрібно супроводжувати і
також в нас ми ми міжнародний ліцей
шарле де голя
і останн пункт це модернізація
комунікації в в нашому
закладі тому що завжди є проблеми з
комунікацією Як ви знаєте і Наступне Що
я хотів хотів би сказати це виклики з
якими ми стикаємося то
тобто То тобто є виклики які нас Ми не
можемо ними керувати наприклад зменшення
демографічна проблеми зменшення
населення тобто тобто це вимагатиме
можливо змін у нашій
організації і кілько зменшення кількості
викладачів
можливо наступна викли це
орієнтація супровід і орієнтації
він продовжується Протягом цього
навчального
курсу і це дуже важливо тому що потрібно
підготовувати учнів в їх орієнтації на
вищу вищу
освіту тобто вони будуть там або йти до
університетів або до підготовчих
курсів кла вони
можуть навчатися в університеті
бургундії Потрібно також їх готувати
до майбутнього навчання нових технологій
наприклад це це достатньо складно
і потрібно потрібно пояснити як учням
так і їхім батькам що це дуже важливо ці
нові технології і з ними працює також
національний
психолог
і є є дуже добре програмне забезпечення
ції яке дуже добре працює нас
і на наступне це і дуже важливо Це
штучний інтелект це дуже Ми зрозуміли що
це дуже важливо і ми створили
таке утворення який займається цим
штучним інтелектом там
і якщо ми
бажаємо навчати громадян потрібно щоб
щоб їх навчали не тільки в
регіоні Мими ми
працюємо із і
із викладачами які викладають як
французьку мову для іноземців так
і так і інших мов навчаємо і щ Я би
сказав що наш проект є що ее ее як хоч
хоча ми працюємо в
[музика]
в працюємо в ліцеї який додуже добре
організований але ми бачимо що деякі
Учні не дуже себе добре почуваються І
тому потрібно
турбуватися про них турбота - це дуже
важливо то то що як як зробити щоб щоб
проявляти турботу про цих учнів Ну
але ліцей це не тільки учні але є і
викладачі
учителі
потрібно потрібно
щоб в ліцеї
забезпечувались стосунки між учнями між
учнями
і
викладачами
от на нашому рівні як зробити з ліцея
таку якби фабрику
таку існуючого світу Дякую за за ваше
увагу в нас Шановні колеги в нас
завершилася перша частина презентації я
передаю слово Лілі Михайлівні і вона нас
далі зорієнтує як
ми
е дякуємо дякуємо нашим промовцям дуже
цікаві були презентації Я хочу
повідомити що на ваш qr-код і
презентація Андреаса шляйхера уже
завантажена і презентація пані Дюваль і
презентація пані матсін Тобто ви зможете
їх детально повернутись до них і
розглянути але ще перед тим як ми підемо
на коротку перерву скажу кілька
узагальнюю слів на що я б хотіла
звернути увагу всієї нашої аудиторії яка
сьогодні з нами тут і яка дивиться нас
онлайн тому що і досвід Естонії і
Франції пронизує основна ідея ідея
мотивації учнів старшого шкільного віку
через
вибір і всі дослідження підтверджують що
цей вибір є неймовірно
важливим ми бачимо що цей вибір може
бути різною мірою сьогодні есто в
презентації Естонії ми чули про третину
навчального часу за вибором але Естонія
планує реформу Я не знаю Як Вас мене
вразили їхні амбітні плани тому що
принцип переходу до
персоналізації навчання і освіти замість
інституціоналізації тобто коли в одному
і тому самому закладі можна обирати свій
шлях індивідуальний комбінуючи
академічні предмети і якщо ви маєте
бажання професійні
курси причому Чи ви зауважили що тут є
ще один план пов'язаний з тим щоб дати
учням спробувати себе також за
професійним напрямком і на базі однієї
інституції пропонувати весь широкий
широку палітру вибо
я щиро зичу нашим естонським колегам теж
успіху і тут це дуже
цікавий цікавий підхід який Сподіваюся
їм вдасться реалізувати ще що
важливо в обої
презентації обов'язково об'єднує питання
10-го класу і лише 10ти обов'язкових
курсів нагадаємо що на противагу
українськи освіті У нас є 20 предметів
які навчаються е у вивчаються у старших
класах але тут мене особливо вразила
теза Андреаса шляйхера що ми не додаємо
12-й рік колеги ми додаємо 10тий клас як
той додатковий рік аби наші діти змогли
визначитися і дозріти до цього вибору і
це дуже така фундаментальна зміна в
підході Дякуємо андрас за те що ви це
підкреслили е і тут важлива річ про те
як ми маємо допомогти визначитися їм
Зверніть увагу що у французькій системі
освіти 54 години щороку на наставництво
і є люди які вміють це робити які
володіють відповідними технологіями і
інструментами для того щоб допомогти
відкрити ці здібності допомогти
спланувати освітню і професійну кар'єру
е наших старших учнів і без сумніву це
безцінній безцінний досвід який Також ми
маємо врахувати е формуючи архітектуру
нашої старшої профільної школи колеги
після перерви ми повернемося сюди до
досвіду Німеччини А зараз оголошується
коротка перерва вона справді буде
коротка е-е але але
е наступна сесія почнеться пізніше Ми
змушені врахувати щоб дати 15 хвилин
перерви Отже о
12:15 Запрошуємо всіх до
зали
всі повернулися Подивіться будь ласка
одне на одного на своїх
сусідів Так ми маємо продовжувати
оскільки вже трішечки вибиваємося з
графіку але я думаю нам вдасться
оперативно зараз надолужити втрачений
час ми плавно переходимо до презентації
Німеччини і
я тоді ра запрошую до
слова хотів би я
запросити пана крістофера текстор
керолін кубе і Мартіна грайбен що
представляють німецьку землю
Хес там знаходиться
Франкфурт Крістофер текстер керівник
Департаменту в Міністерстві освіти і
землі ен
також він входить до робочої групи
земельної яка вітає українських
студентів в німецькій освітній
системі представляє школу
кур у місті Франкфурт і вони обидва
входять в команду управління школо
керолінкуба є керівником школи та
вчителем англійської Мартін йн директор
навчання також
керівник старшої
середньої частини даної школи передам
слово панові текстеру чи могли б ви будь
ласка Доброго дня з
Німеччини Дуже
дякую Я би хотів вам повідомити про
структуру освіти в
Німеччині тому що ми маємо федеральну
систему федеративну систему в нас 16
земель в
нашій
Республіці
і
тому системи освіти є всі в 16 землях
так само як в 24х областях
України
наша система освіти трохи
відрізняється від інших
країн тому що протягом перших чотирьох
років всі студенти навчаються спільно
учні точніше а вже після того наша
система дозволяє різні ко системи
навчання для різних
проможностей і в рамках середньої
школи вона
організована на три роки і останній рік
в
Німеччині є дуже
важливим тому
що в нас починається професійно-технічна
школа тому що дуже важливо підготуватися
до університету з двох
сторін
і інша система є трьохрічна і мій
колега розповість вам про систему
середньої
школи але є також інша
можливість відправитися до
університету на основі вже
професійної-технічної школи або з
подвійної системи якщо гарні оцінки є є
подвійна система можна відправитися до
університету вступити до університету і
кількість студентів
вища які саме отримують на Вищий бал при
вступі до
університету в наших 16
землях є система від 10 до 16
років може відрізнятися в різних
землях Трохи але в
Німеччині
в нас
є міністерство
культури і там є 16
земель Ми там обговорюємо
і доводимо певні стандарти для всієї
Німеччини для всіх 16 земель
Німеччини
бачимо середню школу що найважливіше
це гімназія
це нижчий рівень потім є середня
школа в Німеччині вона триває 3
роки в деяких школах Німеччини можливо
також Через 12 років стати абітурієнтом
але більшість школ
десятирічні це є гімназія плюс середня
школа ви бачите
сторони там
можливо відправитися піти на іспит
у відповідно професійно-технічної школи
і часом можна вже відправитися
безпосередньо до
університету часо можна доєднатися до
університету після 10 років
отже за освіту відповідають
16 земель дуже
важливо щоб при цьому були приведені
національні
стандарти за останні 20
років наше Міністерство культури дуже
багато запровадила
стандартів і останній
стандарт такий
що в нас є неоднакові іспити в 16 землях
вступні іспити але в нас є певні правила
і в кожній
землі вони затверджують власні правила
власну систему
[музика]
вступу наші колеги які спеціалізуються
на різних предметах вони розкажуть більш
детально як це відбувається в кожній
школі
що стосується
іспитів після того
як уже прослухав учень повний курс
можливо один рік ще провести в школі щоб
отримати кваліфікацію потім ще два роки
а потім в нас великий іспит
відбувається і в нас певні є
завдання які однакові для всієї
Німеччини але не на 100% як ви це
побачите
потім маємо також іспити 16 земель трохи
різні і тому що наш навчальний план для
16 земель в них є певні правила для
всієї країни і певні правила є
специфічні
для даної
землі за останні 20
років після останньої
реформи в нас було дуже дуже багато
дискусій Як же це можливо але іспити на
одному
рівні від півночі до півдня
Німеччини але в
хесені
в нас столиця місто Франкфурт віспаден
столиця але найбільше місто Франкфурт ми
знаходимося посередині
Німеччини
але 30 років
тому вступні іспити були досить інші
зовсім не такі як в Баварії зовсім не
такі як в Берліні тепер це наша мета
саме міністерства культури льмініister
confфerence має таку мету перед собою
що в
нас є однакові стандарти але
водночас треба це визнавати що всі землі
різні кожна земля різна і тут ви бачите
що наш начальний план який ми маємо в
Німеччині має
такожперестворюється інститутом якості
освіти є такий інститут якості
освіти
і в нас є певні завдання що стосується
вступу вступних
іспитів ви бачите що в Німеччині в нас
більш як 8
млнв учнів це
дані 19го року це для нас важливо тому
що останні роки в Німеччині зазвичай в
нас
є зменшення кількості учнів їх стає все
менше і менше але за останні 8 років в
Німеччині В нас дуже велика
міграція так і великі зміни
сталися щодо
шкіл і ви можете бачити
що на наступному
слайді лише українських
студентів точніше В Німеччині більш як
200 000
учнів і в них гарні знання
Але вони ж не знають освітньої мови саме
німецькою і це є дуже-дуже великий
виклик для наших шкіл щоб
навчати учнів із країн не лише з
України навіть дуже-дуже багато учнів
приходять з Європейського Союзу і
особливо в
2015-16му І тепер в даний момент також
маємо все більше учнів з
Афганістану
Ірану Туреччини в даний
час
Отже німецькі учні отримують високу
кваліфікацію 34% з них вступають до
університету але їхня частка вища тому
що до 50% можуть вступити до
університетів тому що вони отримають
відповідну кваліфікацію в
професійно-технічній
школі не лише на в середній школі також
професійно-технічно школі інша частина
така що
6% закінчують без отримання освіти без
отримання кваліфікації точніше 6%
закінчують без отримання
кваліфікації раніше було біля нуля але
тепер вище тому що багато-багато учнів з
інших країн приходять до
Німеччини не маючи досвіду навчання в
школі і ви бачите що
особливо ці цифри в хесені саме в землі
хесен 8 мільнів учнів в
Німеччині і в моїй землі
геен
8000 вони йдуть до загально школи і 180
000 відправляються до професійної
технічних шкіл 800 000 загалом 8 млні по
Німеччині учнів і ми бачимо що в моїй
землі гесен
40% учнів мають міграційне минуле і ви
бачите що це не лише ті учні які
народилися в землі гесен а є дуже-дуже
багато учнів які приїхали за останні 8і
років в моїй землі хесен більш як 135
000 135 000 учнів прибули з листопада
2015го до тепер і це великий виклик для
шкільної системи
особливо щодо потреб учнів наша мета
така
щоб з них багато з іх студентів
мігрантів вступили би до університеті
або до подвійної
системи середньої освіти професійної
технічної освіти подвідної системи тому
що для нашої країни Важливо щоб більше
людей працювало і стали кваліфікованими
працівниками як я вам казав це наші
студенти студенти
мігранти серед наших 800 000 учнів в
гесені і ви бачите
що все більше учнів не знаються на
німецькій мові Минулого місяця ми
зареєстрували ще плюс тися таких
учнів багато учнів з таких країн які не
забезпечують високий рівень освіти тому
дуже важливо навчати академічній
німецькій мові в наших школах Як ви
бачите на наступному
слайді в наших
школах Дослідження
показали є необхідність викладати
академічно вже літературну німецьку мову
для того
щоб учні могли потім
дувати на вищі ступіні освіти або ж на
освіту в вищих вищій
школі Мої колеги розкажуть
вам про
ситуацію
в середній школі на прикладі великої
школи у Франкфурті на
Майні вітання з Німеччини з візбанду
мене звуть Карен я розкажу вам далі про
школу нашу школу імені Карла фон
вайнберга зі мною також колега який
приєднається пізніше тому що він
спеціаліст з старшої середньої школи і
він також належить до команди управління
школою наша
загальноосвітня школа має також і лаку
профільно освіти ми розуміємо що це
найважливіше для забезпечення поточних
потреб учнів як школа
ми працюємо спільно із
асоціацією спорту німе і з елітною
школою футболу ми в 21му році отримали
також винагороду елітної школи
року наше основне завдання надавати
найкращі можливості нашим спортсменам
для того щоб вони могли професійний
спорт поєднувати із формальною освітою
наступний слайд будь ласка от ви
бачите які у нас основні види спорту це
футбол волейбол гандбол теніс настільний
теніс гімнастика є також і екзотичні
види спорту такі як
наприклад бігові ковзани або
гольф ви тут можете трошки побачити наші
успіхи Наші учні брали участь і
вигравали в європейських і світових
чемпіонатах звичайно в національних
чемпіонатах також вони завоювали чимало
награти це наші спортсмени наступний
слайд будь
ласка як ви бачите на мапі Наша школа
знаходиться в місті Франкфурт на Майні У
нас є
також гуртожиток для тих хто
проживає на території школі це тобто
школа із пансіоном і ми пропонуємо
багато різних послуг пов'язаних із
навчанням і тренуванням Тобто це створює
найкращі можливость для спортсменів
наступний слайд будь
ласка
Наразі у нас
12 учнів ітртина з них це професійні
спортсмени Ми також
підтримуємо учнів із
інвалідністю тобто інклюзивність Для нас
це основне
завдання і це наша повсякденна
робота в нас працює 20
вчителів
вони викладають різні предмети мають
різні спеціалізації деякі наприклад
спеціалізуються на роботі із людьми з
інвалідністю в нас є
три так звані інтенсивні класи де
навчаються учні з-за кордону зараз їх
55 ті учні які наразі інтенсивно
вивчають німецьку мову половина цих
учнів з України і ми особливо
підтримуємо українських молодих
спортсменів аби вони вони могли
отримувати тренування на наших
майданчиках і продовжувати кар'єру в
професійному
спорті інші Учні не іноземного
походження переважно із самого
франкфурту і його
околиць
що знаходиться приблизно на відстані в
до 50 км від
Франкфурта Також ми бачимо що До нас
приїжджають спортсмени із віддалених
куточків
Німеччини
нас учні вступають до школи в віці
приблизно
10-11
років і після
девятого
після дев'ятого класу можна
навчатися вже певних напрямках отримати
спеціалізацію з
13 років учні отримують освіту за
спеціальними рівнями наступний слайд
будь ласка Тото ідуть до рівня
а і після останнього девтого року
навчання
50% учнів
починають навчатися у професійних школах
або
починають професійну
кар'єру або ж проходять стажування перед
майбутнім
працевлаштуванням деякі
учні залишають нашу школу вже на етапі
старшої школи тому що вони приймають
пропозиції від інших освітніх закладів і
саме там вони отримують вже атестат про
повну середню освіту
Дуже дякую Тепер передам слово колезі ми
спробуємо наздогнати час наздогнати наш
графік з якого ми вибилися і Тепер
давайте подивимося на наступний слайд
так Саме
цей як зазначив вже
Крістофер на самому
початку наша
Старша школа триває ри
роки два семестри першого року це
вступна
фаза що дозволяє здійснити перехід
від середньої школи до старшої школи і
далі починається так звана стадія
кваліфікації яка завершується отриманням
атестату і цей іспити на атестат
дозволяють потім вступити до
університету тож ми ділимо цю старшу
школу на дві стадії Дякую наступний
слайд будь ласка мені
потрібен в старшій
школі
учні можуть обирати собі курси різного
рівня вони можуть
обирати те що їх
кавець тут ми бачимо це
праворуч Вибачте не бачимо ми цього
праворуч наступний слайд будь ласка нам
потрібен Я дуже
перепрошую щось у нас далі не рухається
презентація Ось так я перепрошую тож
ліворуч ми бачимо
що учні можуть спеціалізуватися у
конкретних
предметах а під час етапу кваліфікації
вони обирають так звані поглиблені курси
і спеціалізовані предмети за своїм
вибором
це поглиблені курси пропонують більше
годин навчання на
тиждень тож можна обрати наприклад Два
поглиблені спеціалізовані курси або ж
навіть
три і на базовому рівні вимог ви бачите
ці вимоги
ліворуч обов'язковими предметами є
німецька мова математика іноземні мови і
принаймні один предмети з природничих
наук те що ви бачите ліворуч це
обов'язково звичайно якщо проходить
спеціалізацію то можуть додаватися
предмети з обов'язкових предметів нічого
виключити не можна ось ми бачимо
обов'язкові предмети учні
мають прослухати ці дисципліни в старші
школи
не ми поділили це предмет на сфери
завдань це мова література мистецтво
соціаль науки математика наука і
технології Це третя сфера
так фізичне виховання не включене в
жодну сферу завдань але фізичне
виховання це теж обов'язковий предмет
для німецьких учнів вони впродовж всіх
цих трьох років старшої школи
зобов'язані займатися фізкультурою
наступний слайд будь
ласка це те саме трошки
детальніше німецька мова іноземні мови
мистецтво
література математика
Це ті предмети які обов'язково
викладаються під час х трьох років
старшої школи За ці три роки проте учні
мають і певний
вибір наступний слайд будь
ласка по завершенню цих трьох
років відбувається так званий іспит
абітур іспит який дозволяє отримати
атестат з яким вже можна складати іспити
на вступ в
університет 2
третини цих оцінок в
атестаті досягається За ці два останні
роки тобто по суті іспит наприкінці
старшої школи
не робить основного внеску в середній
бал який учень назбирав впродовж двох
останніх років навчання наступний слайд
будь ласка це те що я казав тут ось ви
бачите це 2
третини фінального
результату накопичується під час
кваліфікаційної стадії під час цих двох
років і остання третина додається за
рахунок цього іспиту заключного іспиту
і розкажу трошки про особливості нашої
школи я з зацікавленням прослухав
доповідь пана Андреаса шлайхера який
говорив про вибір і ми в нашій школі теж
намагаємося цього вибору дати трохи
більше Дуже
дякую Я наприкінці скажу вам ніколи не
забуду слів українських учнів які
навчаються тут в Німеччині вже півтора
року ми їх Питали де кращеа система в
Німеччині чи в
Україні і нам учні сказали
один з учнів сказав всі країни однакові
але не важливіше які правила встановлює
вчитель тобто організація дуже важлива
і дуже важливо щоби вчитель сам був
мотивований захоплений Дуже дякую
Дякуємо колеги за цю лаконічну Але
інформативну презентацію дякую
паля без
мікрофонуею справді цікаво я лише для
такого короткого підсумку і щоб ми це
собі зафіксували хотіла б привернути
увагу до кількох таких акцентів цієї
презентації німецьких
колег специфіка освітньої системи
Німеччини полягає в тому що в 16
федеральних земель своя освітня програма
Але незважаючи на цю різноманітність Яка
ще множується різноманітністю вибору в
профільній старшій школі У них є система
іспитів і
система оцінки результатів навчальних
досягнень яка все-таки стає таким
конкретним спільним якорем який дозволяє
потім рухатися в національній системі
освіти і студентам і
в відповідно вимогам ринку праці е
відповідати тому що пропонує освітня
система Тому це свідчить про те що коли
ми моделюємо нашу старшопрофільну школу
ми обов'язково маємо і моделювати
систему оцінювання і ця система
оцінювання має бути частиною концепції
старшої профільної школи зверніть увагу
скільки наші німецькі колеги присвятили
часу адаптації українських дітей оцьому
питанню цьому виклику з яким сьогодні
дні стикнулася німецька система
освіти хочу сказати що Українську
систему
освіти така подібна адаптація але ще з
більшими викликами чекає незабаром в
Великому обсязі а саме це і ті діти на
яких ми очікуємо щоб вони повернулися з
інших з різних освітніх
систем і їм потрібно буде адапти
адаптуватися до національної системи
освіти і ті діти з різних регіонів
України які по-різному переживають війну
мають власний досвід і це означає що
мають різні навчальні втрати і для нас
буде дуже важливо яким чином і зокрема і
в системі старшої профільної школи ми
будемо надолужувати ці особливості ці
навчальні втрати і третій момент про
інклюзію зрештою це пов'язано з
інклюзією про що я зараз говорила але
мова йде і про не тільки широку інклюзію
а саме інклюзію для тих дітей які мають
інвалідність і яку
пропозицію по їх супроводу і відповідно
по можливості здобути старшу профільну
школу зверніть увагу адже в Україні на
відміну наприклад від Німеччини чи
навіть від Естонії чи від Франції досвід
яких ми сьогодні вже слухали старша
профільна школа є обов'язковою і
гарантована конституцією і це означає що
ми маємо
передбачити цю можливість вибору
підтримку і супровід для кожної
української дитини для кожного
українського
учня колеги ми зараз переходимо До сесії
поглиблених інтерв'ю з нашими промовцями
думаю що це має бути саме найцікавіша
сесія і розпочнемо Ми з Естонії будь
ласка будь
ласка
та основної програми навчання
Міністерства освіти та науки колишнього
керівника школи із
Польщі пан Артур є директором
департаменту як я вже сказав Але перед
тим як працювати в Міністерстві освіти
він працював у школі і має багато років
досвіду як керівник школи в Польщі під
час зустрічі він буде говорити про
старшу середню освіту з точки зору
Міністерства і також Як колишній
керівник школи тому я думаю що в нас
буде дуже цікава
презентація пане Артур Чи ви є з
нами
слуша па Так я з вами мене дуже добре
чутно я передаю слово
повноваженому міністра освіти і науки з
питань профільних навчальних програм
передусім Я хотів би подякувати вам за
запрошення взяти участь в сьогоднішній
зустрічі в даному
семінарі і я спробую щоб мій виступ був
зрозумілим в рамках свого виступу я
розповім про систему освіти Польщі з
акцентом на профільні школи в польська
система освіти починаючи з 2017 року
переживала процес трансформації цей
процес трансформації полягав передусім в
тому що
е власне збільшився етап е основної
базової школи раніше було шість років а
після цього цей період подовжився будь
ласка дайте наступний
слайд Дякую Отже раніше було шість років
основної базової школи починаючи з 17-го
року системмі загальної
освіти власне основна базова школа
Почала діяти вісім років і Відповідно ми
сьогодні маємо основну базову школу 8
років після дляля цього йде чотирирічний
загальноосвітній ліцей потім наприклад
може бути пть років
технікуму три роки наприклад це може
бути ПТУ першого
рівня відповідно можна отримати
профільну
освіту існують також післяліцеальні
школи які тривають 2 з по роки На даному
слайді
представлено будь ласка наступний
слайд На даному слайді
представлено власне основні етапи
здобування освіти Отже вісім років це
основна базова школа потім чотири роки
наприклад це може бути Старша школа так
званий загальноосвітній ліцей або
п'ятирічний технікум трирічне ПТУ
пізніше після якого наприклад учні
можуть подовжувати продовжувати навчання
для того щоб здобути Вищу профільну
освіту після завершення наприклад
середньої школи Вони можуть поступити у
ВУЗ якщо вони не будуть здавати
випускних іспитів так званого ЗНО то
вони можуть продовжувати навчання в так
званого ПТУ будь ласка наступний слайд в
польській системі
освіти діє так
зване обов'язок щоби всі діти закінчили
основну базову школу тобто вісім
років
натомість до
18го до 18 років власне Учні повинні
закінчити основну базову
школу і після цього більшість учнів
вибирає продовження навчання в так
званій старшій школі або як я вже
говорив так зване чотирирічне
загальноосвітнє ліцей е щодо шкіл на Як
то кажуть середньому рівні Е то
відповідно за їх функціонування школ
відповідає територіальні органи місцевої
влади основна базова школа е власне за
їх функціонування відповідають найменші
адміністративні одиниці органів
місцевого самоврядування
саме вони виконують основні Як то кажуть
завдання щодо центрального бюджету то
органи місцевого самоврядування
отримують так звану
компенсацію яка є частиною прибутку яка
скеровується передусім на
функціонування середніх шкіл натомість
за
функціонування шкіл це передусім
покладається на органи місцевого
самоврядування саме вони витрачають
левову частку коштів на ті цілі будь
ласка наступний слайд на цьому слайді
представлено Скільки
учнів на так званому середньому рівні
тобто чотирирічний загальноосвітній
ліцей на даний рік тобто
2324 рік Отже ми бачимо що їх майже
000 що стосується власне ПТУ е майже
755 000 учнів е Тобто це трирічне ПТУ
першого рівня
і вище професійно-технічне училище
другого рівня Ми маємо майже 130 000
учнів Ой вибачайте
1 350 учнів наступний слайд будь ласка
На даному слайді
представлено кількість навчальних
закладів
маємо загалом
2000 400 загальноосвітніх ліцеїв Тобто
це які заміняють так званого старшу
школу майже
1695 технікумів
1858 ПТУ різного
рівня в усіх типах шкіл про які я вже
згадував тобто загальноосвітні ліцеї
технікуми а також профільні
ПТУ діє базова
програма обов'язково базова
програма
яка розробляється на центральному рівні
І діє загалом в усіх освітніх установах
країні
профільні заклади Власне вони беруть
загальноосвітні якісь предмети натомість
що стосується профільних предметів то
для них існує окрема
програма але структура її дуже
подібна відповідно
залежно від обсягу матеріалу і так далі
залежно від профілю від специфіки того
чи іншого ПТУ від специфіки того чи
іншого профілю оскільки учні
здобувають певну профільну
освіту відповідно в них є загальний
компонент який є обов'язковим і так
званий окремий профільний компонент за
яким здійснюється вка
учнів будь ласка два слайди вперед
прогорніть ще
один
базова навчальна програма визначається
на центральному рівні розпорядження
міністра осві і науки і
вона власне реалізується вчителями а
також дирекцією навчальних
закладів в рамках навчальних програм
програма навчання може мати розширений
характер залежно від того що передбачено
в законі Про навчальні програми закон
Про навчальні програми визначає мінімум
який має бути
вчителями на тому чи іншому рівні
підготовки тобто залежно від того для
якого рівня скерована
програма базова
програма або
основа є своєрідним критеріумом для
власне зовнішніх іспитів тобто аналогу
так званого
ЗНО
перший такий іспит складають учні після
завершення основної базової школи тобто
Після восьми років навчання це один з
елементів які береться до увагу при
прийнятті учнів наприклад на до старшої
школи і потім іде випускні іспити які
здаються Після чотирьох років навчання в
загальноосвітньому ліцеї чи після
закінчення технікуму залежно від того
яку який саме заклад вибирають учні
тобто немає окремого документу який би
визначав обсяг
вимогів які
перевіряються в учнів базові скажемо так
програми є визначником або
показником Як то кажуть рівня
навчання А також є основною вимогою яку
за якою слідкує Центральна комісія
центральноосвітня
комісія будь ласка наступний
слайд як я вже
згадував після основної базової школи
учні можуть вибрати ту чи іншу форму
подальшого
навчання
тобто
Вибір є в
них
тобто
е Скажімо так від їхнього від їхніх
результатів завершення основної базової
школи залежить їх можливість чи
потраплять
вони до загальноосвітнього ліцею чи вони
змушені будуть на основі іспиту
випускного іспиту Після восьми років
навчання продовжувати навчання в якомусь
іншому навчальному закладі відповідно
залежно від рівня вони можуть продовжити
як я вже казав навчання або в
загальноосвітньому ліцеї або в
технікумі
е тобто в
старші школі наприклад учні мають
можливість переходити від одного рівня
до іншого Ну наприклад в другому класі
технікуму Наприклад якщо учень визнає
що
більш цікавішо для нього є навчання в
загальноосвітньому
ліцеї і відповідно якщо він задумається
продовжувати подальше навчання у вищому
навчальному
закладі то відповідно в нього є така
можливість переходу що гарантує йому
базова програмна
основа є певні
відмінності які стосуються переліку
предметів які і вимагаються від не учня
щоб він їх опанував Але такий перехід є
можливий і передбачений в нашій системі
освіті тобто після восьмого
класу відповідно учні мають певний вибір
або завершити навчання або продовжувати
його в
подальшому або в ліцеї або в технікумі
для того щоб потім здати випускний іспит
і мати можливість поступити у Вищий
навчальний заклад зовнішнє незалежн
оцінювання або ж екзамен зрілості як він
відбувається Я
перепрошую що стосується загальної
освіти це стосується з предметів
основної бази навчальної програми той
факт що основна базова програма була
введена у польській системі у
2017-2020 роках коли з'явилася нова
програма навчання з основних предметів
Зараз в неї
вносяться зміни і ця ці Ця програма
базувалася е на припущені що слід
забезпечити учням загальну
освіту а вусьька спеціалізація в свою
чергу вводиться порівняно пізно
і Це спеціально зроблено для того
щоб школа і освіта в першу
чергу була призначена для загального
розвитку і для розвитку потенційних
здібностей учня саме це відображено у
наших екзаменах зрілості і вже згодом
для особистого розвитку для вибору
професійної стежки є професійна освіта і
підготовка для е забезпечення потреб
ринку праці і натомість потреби ринку
праці Вони повинні визначати як
виглядатиме професійна освіта і
спеціальна освіта і зараз як виглядає
загальна
освіта учні
е проходять курси певних загальних
предметів загального циклу це наприклад
польська мова математика знання про
науки про суспільство біологія хімія
фізика це стосується ліцеїв тобтож
старшої школи Це ті предмети які
проходять учні
це обов'язкові предмети для учнів всіх
типів шкіл натомість Кожен учень
вибираючи екзамен зрілості
із якоїсь спеціалізації додає собі до
цієї групи загальноосвітніх предметів ті
предмети які можна назвати його
профільними предметами і він цей предмет
найчастіше вивчає на розширеному рівні
під час у старшій школі або у
технікумах і в ліцеї або у технікумі
розпочинаючи вивчає цей предмет на
поглибленому рівні і аж до екзамену
зрілості тобто до останнього випускного
класу і
з поступово до в міру наближення до
екзамену зрілості зникають із програми
вивчення загальні загальноосвітні
предмети і власне як виглядає наш
екзамен зрілості хочу вам
розповісти як я
згадував цей екзамен є зовнішнім
тестуванням він проводиться Центральною
екзаменаційною
комісією тестові а куші п
готуються на всю країну для усіх учнів і
Приступити до цього екзамену можуть учні
які завершують загальноосвітню старшу
школу або ж технікуми
абоąз jest przystąpiie доów устnyх гzam
з ęzyка поlskego I ęzyka obceg
nowoynegoowiązk zdan C aminów
pisemny na poziomie
podstawowym język polski matematyka I
wybrany przez ucznia język
obcy już nie zawsze nowożytny BO od tego
roku szkolnego uczniowie mogąwać
tak otworzyła się też moż zwania języka
łńiegoskiej S
możeizow szły podstawowej na takich
samych zasadach Jak język obcy nowożytny
Ten który jest wybierany jako drug
niowie polscy od sidj klasy szkoły
podstawowej poczynając wbierają drugi
język obcy którego zaczynają się zyć i
również z języka łacińskiego będą mogli
tutaj zdawać zdawać łac czy przi c
zaminy pisemne na poziomie podстаawowym
język polski matematyka I języк obcy
oraz Jen na poziomie roроzszeжо вибрани
збрани з уч прошу колейний
слайд броц под увага
тоesowia
уówiecudów
uczniwie mogą dobierać sobie przedmioty
dodatkow wynik maturalny
jest
kryterium tak naprawdę
determinuje rekrutac na na studia wyższe
określa listę Katalog przedmiotów K
uczeń musi zć
żeby
kunek dowiadują się jakie przedmioty
muszą mieć na świadectwie maturalny i
dobierają sobie Z katalogu przedmiotów
dodatkowych te które tutaj mają państwo
na slajdzie
wymienione wyniki matury są przepustką
do studiów
[музика]
wyższych zy
sy naszy systemie szkolnył bardzo
istotną rolę także takiego
ftra poproszę O kolejny
slйd to Taka dodatkowa
informacja że naomie szkół średn
funkcjonują też szkoły
któreerują
przygowaniej prowadzone przez rżne
resorty na przykład ministerstwo obrony
narodowej
prowadzi jednostki oddziały
przygotowania przygotowania wojskowego w
tych klasach obenia
ogóztałącegizacj podstawy
programowejie Same Jak w innych szkołach
dochodzą jeszcze zajęcia I
zadenia specj ie szkoły rów istnieją są
to oddziały na
przykład szkoły
dwęzyczne
lubziały
przygotowaniaego
wspomniałem rekrutacj tych szkół
obok wyników Z egzaminu
oklasisty brane są podę czy
przeprowadzeą testy specjalistycz
ką dzy uczniów w
dane są w stanie czy
są
naukiie klasy
czy danym tyie
szkoły dziękuję państwu za uwagę mam
nadzieję
że sposób możliwie czytelny
przedstawiłem strukturęniwa
redniego w
polsceęnie odwiem
teraz I w późnieйszej części już
panelowй dyсusjne na
еwentтутаaniaкtre się
поjawiкую
you так Шановні колеги все
втому Перепрошую щиро за цей технічний
збій на щастя для української аудиторії
ну польська мова є досить близькою І ми
мали слайди на екрані на двох Оста
слайдах уже збій відбувся Я перепрошую
перед іншими колегами Я думаю ми потім
розмістимо також презентацію англійською
мовою в папці і можна буде переглянути
цю цей маленький фрагмент випущеної
інформації ще й англійською мовою а
тепер аби не забирати час Бо ми дуже
тісно рухаємося зустріч в зустріч
Скажіть будь ласка чи працює в нас
англійський переклад так
Так так
Добре Ну що тоді давайте рухатися
[музика]
далі
теперь я не слышу
его Отже
ми
послухали послухаємо Елісон ми вас
бачимо і щиро вас вітаємо тож будь ласка
Очікуємо на Вашу презентацію Вітаю Дякую
запрошення Ви мене чуєте так
чуємо
такую я зроблю короткий огляд нашої
системи перш ніж ми конкретно перейдемо
про підхід пов'язаний із
кваліфікаціями Я хотіла би побачити свої
слайди на
екрані Отже на першому слайді ми маємо
не зупинятися давайте даліру
це власне огляд системи освіти Британії
Я перепрошую тут не все можна було
перекласти і як якщо у вас будуть
питання якщо ви в чомусь не впевнені то
будь ласка ставте питання Отже освіта в
Англії є обов'язково з Віку 5ти років до
18 і багато
дітей
відвідують дитячий садок
шановнін Чи Ви не могли б трошки
відсунути далі
мікрофон трошки далі від губ тому що ми
чуємо як
фонить не дуже добре звук іде Дуже дякую
А так
краще А от тепер трошки ближче десь
посередині ось так можли о так так Я
думаю що так буде гарно Супер
дякую Тож як я казала освіта в Англії
обов'язково здобувається з 5ти до 18
років і до цього діти отримують
дошкільні заклади з п'яти років вже
державна освіта є
обов'язковою У нас є ключові
етапи якими дитина рухається перше ніж
перейти до освіти в вищій школі або вже
перейти до ринку
праці ми маємо загальну програму для
середньої школи Ця програма завершується
для учнів в віці 16 років На цей момент
вони вже мають знати що будуть робити
далі І
далі з
років дітей вже школа випускає у світ
праці у віці 16
років учні
отримують остаточну вичтку академічних
предметів і з 18 вони вже починають
обирати собі подальший
шлях
20% обирають
академічні
предмети
також є частка з учнів які обирають
виключно технічні предмети також є
комбінація з цих
варіантів Також у
нас осві надається інституційними
провайдерами я трошки згодом розкажу про
типи скул типи шкіл Які в нас присутні
і
після років учні можуть обрати між
завершенням освіти і переходом до
більшої спеціалізації на наступному
слайді ви
бачите скільки дітей навчається в школах
в Англії
і у нас
приблизно
мільйон вчителів а і іншого
непедагогічного
персоналу ви бачите що в
спеціалізованих закладах навчається
трошки
менше учнів і далі в наступному
слайді в Англії існує достатньо складний
ландшафт шкільний ландшафт У
нас різні типи шкіл Нам потрібен
наступний слайд
перепрошую для мене нічого не змінилося
Ну ладно будемо рухатись далі Отже
складний шкільний
ландшафт є школи які утримуються
місцевими органами влади є так звані
школи які координуються
академіями це результат реформи що
відбувалися в Англії останні 15
років школи достатньо автономні вони
можуть самостійно визначати свої
програми
і тут більше на слайді у нас детали я не
буду зараз вам про них все пояснювати
далі на наступному слайді ви бачите
інформацію про шкільну стратегію вона
спря на те щоби Кожен учень отримав
належну підтримку і щоб вона надходила
своєчасно Для цього існують високі
стандарти
нікого не здивую що в основі освіти
знаходиться якість підготовки
вчителів і у нас
є чимало доказів того що блискучих
вчителів діти дійсно щиро Вітають
ми
насичуємо програми знаннями знання є
основою для програми
і
[музика]
е у нас також елементу стратегії є
адресна підтримка ми тут
бачимо Переваги
індивідуалізованого підходу люди
які мають невигідне економічне становище
мають право на підтримку Ми прагнемо їх
теж залучити і Звичайно що також кра
наріжним камнем є сама
система ми трошки більше поговоримо
зараз про програмне наповнення Дякую
Давайте перевіримо чи ви мене чуєте так
Так
дякую Отже на наступному слайді ви
бачите ключові елементи
програми
національна про грама та точніше її
реформа була впроваджена у 14му році
після того як ми у нас змінився уряд
10му році тобто дуже багато тексту на
цих слайдах Я сподіваюсь що ми можемо в
збільшеному вигляді їх побачити тож
національна програма в
Англії Перепрошую якщо це вже чули Але
скажу що це саме програма Англії Англії
а не Великої Британії
інші члени королівства мають свої
організаційні умови тож в
Англії національна
програма визначає на високому рівні те
що має
викладатися але школи мають гнучкість в
організації контенту
змісту відповідно до потреб різних груп
зацікавних сторін також Дбаємо про те
щоб програма була наповнена контентом
наповнена
знаннями
ми як казали вже вважаємо що програма
має бути послідовною і послідовно вести
учня до досягнення результатів така
програма надає найкращі можливості для
навчання учнів ключові елементи які ми
тут хотіли б згадати це доказова да
коіка Це стандарти це матеріали
які переносяться в країну найкращі
міжнародні практики аби Наші учні теж
досягали
найкращих
результатів Ну наприклад застосовуємо
підходи які використовуються в країнах
Азії в
сингапурі це особливо підхід для
навчання
математиці далі ще один важливий елемент
це
підзвітність наші державні школи повинні
дотримуватися національної
програми але
загалом вони можуть збалансовано
визначати свою програму Вони мають
більше свободи в деяких ключових
сферах
наша наші школи підлягають інспектуванню
з боку держави інспекція стежить за тим
як впроваджується програма так щоб
заохочувати підтримувати навчання
учнів ми також відстежимо засвоєння
основних предметів за допомогою
показника
ібек це
показник який дозволяє виміряти
успішність зсвання різних адикамічних
предметів Ми підтримуємо різні моделі
наприклад утворення хабів коли група
шкіл надають досвід і підтримку іншим
школам в таких сферах як наприклад
математика англійська мова вони
обмінюються досвідоми і найкращими
практиками Ну і нарешті ми маємо так
звані
академії які опікуються різними
предметами відповідно до національної
програми дозволяючи учителям вже
розвивати свої спроможності наступний
слайд будь
ласка тут праворуч ви бачите таблицю із
переліком предметів на різних
етапах
бачите дві колонки предмети які є
обов'язковим для віку з 11 до 14 із 14
до
ми охоплюємо ці
предметами програмами предметними
програмами і ці програми розробляються
відповідно до конкретних потреб
шкільного закладу і також цікаво
подивитися на комбі
предметів комбінується наприклад
математика і
родознавчі
науки
здоровозбережувальні
предмети
це всі Ці предмети мають викладатися під
час навчання у загальній освітній
школі сподіваюся
що найцікавіше
це те що програми зосереджуються на
знаннях адже знання уможливлюють набуття
навичок навички - це не
самоціль навички
здобуваються на основі знання по суті
навички - це прикладні знання і навички
не існують відокремлено від знань і
також знання і навички є
предметноспецифічними ми говоримо про
знання і навички в контексті конкретного
предмету наступний слайд будь ласка і
нарешті розкажу вам про
кваліфікації є низка академічних і
технічних шляхів
напрямків для підтримки всіх учнів в
розкритті їхнього
потенціалу ми зосереджуємося на віці від
14 до 16 років і в цьому віці
90% учнів
складають
іспити Куди входить іспити з англійської
мови іноземної
мови географії історії
реформа у нас впроваджується зараз до
25го до 25го
року
і
школи прагнуться допомогти учням віці з
14 до 16 набути також знання які не
обов'язково потрібні для здачі
академічних іспитів GC
була
сформована було сформовано підхід до
академічних
предметів
за успішність цих предметах учні можуть
отримати так звані технічні винагороди
які враховуються в їхніх залікових
книжках і після 16 років учні можуть
користуватися цілою низкою
цих технічних
інструментв Дякую наступний слайд будь
ласка Тепер давайте подивимося що далі
йде у нас після 16 років це поглиблений
британський стандарт і це істотна зміна
у нашій освітній
системі
зараз у нас програма дещо коротша ніж
передбачається на
майбутнє
і за поглибленим британським стандартом
50%
учнів
отримують вивчають академічні
предмети 25 технічні і
традиційно
учні обирають від 16 до 18 років
тричотири основні предмети що в принципі
подібно до систем в інших країнах як ми
почули від інших колег Сьогодні у нас
також є амбітна ціль запровадити
бакалаврську модель яка типова у наших
колег в інших
країнах наступний слайд будь ласка
ми можемо його пропустити і давайте
перейдемо на слайди
11 з таблицями зображеннями що ж це
означає для
практики як результати реформи будуть
виглядати на
практиці учні
будуть
вчитися вивчати п'ять-шість предметів
замість
трьохчотирьох буде ширший навчальний
план Таким чином вони будуть мати так
зване
некваліфікаційний
час
який тим не менш не буде сприйматися
відзірно від загальноосвітнього часу і
ми передбачаємо збільшення на 15%
кількості навчальних
годин
і це дозволить збільшити шанси на
працевлаштування
Ми хотіли би продемонструвати учням
різні можливості працевлаштування і
дозволити їм засвовити як загальні
предмети так і більше спеціалізовані ви
бачите знову таки Перепрошую тут не
перекладений цей
слайд
якщо учень вивчає комп'ютерні технології
то зараз дуже популярні
то також буде вивчати наприклад
англійську мову і
Бізнес наприклад Подивіться які предмети
обираються для того щоб став учень
лікарем Це і хімія біологія англійська і
Фізика тож ми з нетерпінням Очікуємо на
провадження цієї реформи Дуже дякую вам
за вашу
увагу Дуже дякую Шановні
колеги Ну а тепер ми переходимо до нашої
наступної презентації після цього у нас
відбудеться обмін питаннями і
відповідями трошки згодом Отже я із
задоволенням Оголошую презентацію метю
ченкса голови департамента середньої
освіти віно втоде за референтну Світуля
вчителів
Метью вів 17 років в керівництві школи і
опікувався як початковою так і середньою
школою шановний метіо бачу що Ви вже наю
з нами ми вас вітаємо і надаємо вам
слово Дуже дякую Дякую що ви мене
запросили і На жаль ми більше не чуємо
мецію
давайте перейдемо на наступний слайд що
ви попередній був просто з моєю
інформацією про мене есон розповідала
вам про різні типи шкіл в Англії А я
представляю академічний
трест і я
пропрацював багато років в освіті зараз
я займаюся організацією в хабів для
вчителів і
також ми готуємо вчителів
підвищуємо кваліфікацію вчителів в
рамках
мультидисциплінарного
тресту
Зараз ми
особливо переймаємося дітьми із
особливими потребами або
з малозабезпечених сімей які зазнали
труднощів особливо після мі наступний
слайд будь
ласка Отже
Елісон говорила переважно про середню
освіту про тих дітей які отримують
сертифікат про повну середню освіту але
я
розкажу як діти
отримують консультування щодо вибору
кар'єри поговоримо також про
профорієнтацію
Як правило в віці 14
років діти починають старшу школу Старша
школа триває три роки деяким дітям
дозволяється
обирати спеціалізацію навіть дещо раніше
але ми це в принципі не хвалюємо тому що
ми вважаємо що до цього віку діти мають
пройти достатній шлях розвитку вивчаючи
збалансовий набір предметів перш ніше
вони почнуть спеціалізацію
даю вам час щоб ви змогли почитати слайд
Я дуже перепрошую
диаграма у нас блоксхема не перекладена
але вона показує про що ми розповідаємо
учням щоб допомогти їм зробити вибір ми
вивчаємо які предмети їх цікавлять
надаємо їм поради рекомендації просимо
їх подумати про людей чия кар'єра чия
професія їм цікава ми не хотіли б
обмежувати вибір
дітей лише якимись конкретними
предметами ми питаємо їх Чим би Вони
хотіли зайнятися вже під час
працевлаштування тощо Тобто ми постійно
підкидаємо їм нові опції нові варіанти
наступний слайд будь
ласка
[музика]
Moment The whole Screen
щось сталося з комп'ютером все
пропало Отже список предметів що ми
бачили на попередньому слайді з df ми
Отак пов'язуємо всі предмети і в нас є
вся база навча го плану 16-18 років
англійська література мова математика
три науки наукові предмети і хочемо щоб
була мова щоб вони вчили мови це важливо
хоча це не є обов'язково і ще одні
опціональні варіанти Отже Ми даємо їм
скерований вибір щоб вони
вибирали і знову ми запитуємо просимо
щоб вони подумали про свій вибір і
задаємо конкретні
питання Які їхні амбіції Які їхні творчі
переваги щоб надати їм скерований вибір
тоді Ця дитина йде в GC і там вчиться
два роки в кінці двох років тоді вони
мають прийняти рішення щодо подальшого
навчання після 16 і ми
пропонуємо після 16 це вже
Ці предмети після 16 років Ось вони Ці
предмети які є на наступному
слайді ось є
варіанти зазвичай учні
вибирають три або чотири предмети
три-чотири предмети вони обирають та
такий же самий така ж процедура
як ми допомагаємо дітям
обрати довкола їхньоїх карєри
майбутньої і тут певні дати
щодо пункту призначення тобто що Вони
вибирають ви бачите у віці 16 Куди вони
йдуть хочуть стати учнями на
виробництві подальша
освіта і дуже багато тут всього єі ці
кількості студентів шість студентів це
пізня
заява часом вони повертаються до
першогодругого рівня кваліфікації
можливо третій рівень їм не підходить
тому ми чекаємо рівня т та реформи
довкола професійно-технічної та
технічної
освіти тут я для вас вказав
різноманітні форми щодо вибору кар'єри
це не є типово для
школи це співбесіди з дітьми два
зовнішніх співбесіди з радниками щодо
кар'єри це допомагає в виборі предметів
є предмети чемпіони тому що є школи з
певними предметами і ті ті предмети які
найбільш
популярні і кожний курс
обирається школою деякі школи пропонують
всі курси які ми показували для рівня а
деякі більше деякі менше в залежності
від персоналу в залежності від
графіку Я хотів вам зробити дуже
короткий огляд я сподіваюся ви візьмете
собі ці слайди керівні принципи щодо
яких ми базуємо наше навчання це
планування щодо викликів високих
очікувань і вомий пункт стосується того
що казали колеги з D це отримання знань
коли вже Вони знають мають ці знання
можуть подавати далі свої навички якщо
ви можете грати музичний інструмент
звичайно чим більше вас знають тим
кращими гратимете це такий принцип
навичків та знань замість того щоб мати
знання щоб потім вже виробляти навички і
тоді вже вдосконалювати
навички перехо від навчального
плану певна підоснова де ж знаходяться
англійські школи що
стосується
набору кадрів збереження кадрів все
складно особливо хімія фізика
комп'ютерні науки учителі сучасної
іноземної мови французької Німеччини їх
важко знайти важко отримати на додаткові
курси тренінгу вони можуть йти від свого
звичайного диплома і
також чотири предмети в Німеччині вони
учать на підвищенні кваліфікації в нас
лише одні один курс підвищення
кваліфікації ми надаємо тренінг вчителям
навчання
вчителям
є Так звана золота нитка навчання Отже
під час життя персонал навчається і
розвиває свої навички
кваліфікацію як Департаменту освіти Ми
цим дуже щільно займаємося останні два
роки і в останнє але не менш
важливе дуже корисно отримати інформацію
як же батьки та діти мають доступ до
шкіл у Великій Британії у віці 11 це на
основі
вибору перевага віддається географічному
місцезнаходження поштовому індексу також
інші варіанти вибору і
і діти вже в березні можуть вибрати
перед тим як вони підуть в школу У
вересні У нас є селективна освіта у
Великій
Британії є по-різному у всіх частинах
але є і граматичні школи Вони все ще
присутні в деяких частинах
країни Буду радий відповісти на питання
трошки в нас пізніше будуть запитання
коли в нас буде сесія питань та
відповідей даний
Вакули ось цей інформаційний блок і я
Раду за запрошую до слова лілію
михайлівну Лілія
Михайлівна за надзвичайно цікаві
презентації Я думаю що сьогодні впродовж
Цього
дня за
презентація поzy
х го
молі вашні школьні прозвучали в цих
презентаціях і які будуть для нас дуже
важливими Коли ми завтра будемо
опрацьовувати власну модель вірніше
проєкт власної моделі і тут хотіла б
звернути увагу на
питання значення професійної орієнтації
учнів в старшій профільній школі А як ви
почули у Англії воно розпочинається вже
у 14 років тобто фактично за два роки до
старшої профільної школи з дітьми е
проводять спеціальну роботу і ми навіть
побачили алгоритм запитань з якими
працюють І що ще важливо Це прозвучало
що залу
залучається спеціально
ее посада про професійного або
кар'єрного радника який супроводжує
дітей і родину так само на цьому шляху е
більше того навіть такий слоган як
профорієнтація як ключова особливість
старшої профільної школи у
Англії воно показує що це є дуже
серйозним пріоритетом і зрештою
пріоритетом для майбутньої
самореалізації яка би мала бути успішною
для кожної людини
е чи ви звернули увагу в останній
презентації на ці вісім ключових
принципів ефективного викладання і мені
здається що це звичайно цим хворіє
українська освіта не тільки в старшій
профільній школі але і в
базовій там серед цих принципів було
постановка питань до дітей таким чином
щоб їх спонукати до
роздумів і до формування власного
власної відповіді на запитання Тобто
це складний Шлях який треба пройти в
тому числі і нашим вчителям до
постановки таких питань і це про
методики викладання ми мало сьогодні
говорили про методики але в них запорука
досягнення результатів і про зворотній
зв'язок у зворотньому зв'язку серед
принципів звучало обов'язковий зворотній
зв'язок послідовним заповненням
прогалин тобто якщо у дитини появляються
прогалини то їх не тільки
треба продемонструвати і виявити а
потрібно Показати шлях яким чином
працювати з цими прогалинами і нарешті
дуже важливо до чого нам слід звернути
увагу це підготовка педагогів і
керівників шкіл тому що будь-яка модель
яку ми можемо опрацювати Вона має шанс
на успіх тільки тоді коли вона і
співтворена і цілком зрозуміла для
впровадження педагогами і керівниками
закладів освіти думаю що це хороші такі
фокуси уваги які нам треба буде взяти до
відома і пропрацювати
завтра колеги ми оголошуємо перерву до
4ї години і о четій годині повертаємося
на поглиблену сесію з запитаннями до
наших презентерів Дякуємо Я лишень додам
що за qr-кодами вже є всі презентації і
українською і англійською мовою тому
якщо ви Раптом щось випустили чи
пропустили або хочете освіжити десь там
напере після кави в пам'яті перед тим як
ставити Запитання Ви можете скористатися
такою нагодою Дякую колеги смачної кави
всім Доброго дня Я
тут Отже Ми почнемо це для мене
так хотіла б розпочати цю дискусію
все-таки з такого питання от з вашої
точки зору що було найбільш для вас
цікавим таким
досвідом
інсайтом якимось постулатом яким був для
вас справді корисним і ви вважаєте що
він би міг бути адаптований або
переосмислений і важливим для моделі
профільної старшої школи в
Україні можливо Олександр
івановичу Дякую
Ну насамперед Я хотів би е подякувати е
експертів які нам дуже цікаво
представили інформацію а і звичайно
подякувати організаторам цього семінару
за дуже вдалий підбір е країн про моделі
яких ми почули Це дійсно країни які
мають своєрідні моделі
які
вирізняються специфікою і тому всі
е
виступи експертів сприймалися з
цікавістю Е що мене вразило
чи я я думаю що дві такі речі які
треба буде і нам використати обов'язково
В нашій моделі українській
ее по-перше це широкий вибір
е учнів
в формуванні власної індивідуальної
траєкторії навчання на профільному рівні
І по-друге це широка автономія особливо
в академічних
свободах в формуванні змісту освіти і в
формуванні профільності тобто Ці дві
речі які
фактично
перекреслюють весь
той попередній досвід Я маю на увазі
який ми мали щодо про фільної освіти
тому що в нас були типові навчальні
плани у нас
було суттєве обмеження можливостей
закладів
освіти якимсь чином впливати на цю
освітню
траєкторію от перші такі враження у мене
дякуємо
дякуємо Олександру івановичу і я хотіла
б також долучити до нашої дискусії пана
Джеймса грешима зі світового банку
ее не знаю чи у Джеймса була можливість
слідкувати за всією цією дискусією вона
була для нас насправді сьогодні дуже
інтенсивна І дуже важлива
е Я сподіваюся що вас теж щось зачепило
я знаю що Ви добре знаєте потреби
України і з цим багато
працюєте ее Як ви
вважаєте який досвід для України був би
цікавим для
переосмислення Дуже дякую за ваше
запитання Дуже дякую за
запрошення звичайно я би хотів
особисто відвідати я не відслідкував
цієї дискусії але я почув дуже
важливі послідовні
повідомлення стосовно деяких викликів і
стосовно
послідовності один з моментів які для
нас важливі в світовому банку під час
підтримки Міністерства освіти та науки
України Ми хотіли би подумати про плани
та
ресурси наприклад було багато
дискусій про за і проти і витрати які
пов'язані з тим Щоб запропонувати різні
рівні вибору для
учнів розширюючи з плином часу даний
рівень
вибору деякі країни які були
представлені вказують на практичні
виклики як це робити на шкільному рівні
які з цим пов'язані
витрати з нашої точки
зору нам треба подумати разом з
міністерством та з вами накі льки це
можливо як побудувати послідовність змін
для цього звичайно з кінцевою метою
щоб системи зосередилися на
компетенціях
соціо емоційних навичках які надобляться
учням на
майбутнє я не сказав би про конкретну
модель
я не маю відповідної позиції для цього
але в мене є певні гарні ідеї стосовно
того як ми можемо підтримати
Міністерство та систему освіти з точки
зору
планування Дякуємо це дуже хороша новина
і це якраз потрібно нам тому що я думаю
що ми рухаємося в дуже правильному
напрямку Спочатку ми вивчаємо найкращий
досвід ми працюємо над архітектурою
системи а тоді звичайно нам потрібно
серйозне сильне партнерство яке допоможе
реалізувати власне нашу національну
модель і Світовий банк якраз і може бути
таким важливим партнером е Я запрошую до
слова пана Романа Роман
очолює роботу над стандартом старшої
профільної школи який вже оприлюднений
для громадського обговорення але все
ще він є на обговоренні і тому ця
дискусія також є дуже вчасна Романе Що
вас вразило Сьогодні який
інсайт для вас можливо є новим цікавим
або таким що от вам хочеться взяти і
зараз щось внести якусь зміну у проєкт
стандарту Ну я почав би з того
що такого формату
дискусія стала можливою не лише через
ваші особисті зусилля через згоду
Андреса в цьому взяти участь особисто і
також інших колег але також тому що ми
Ми розмовляємо зараз з усім світом
єдиною мовою Тобто ми багато зробили
спільно для того аби цю мову
викристалізувати і ввести її у власний
обіг і це ее добра основа Я маю на увазі
ключові компетентності компетентніст і
підхід і в ціло життєвій перспективі що
важливо е ну і тут ніби очевидно що
основний такий лейтмотив Який сьогодні
Звучав упродовж цілого дня в цьому
контексті Це
вибір ми зараз багато сперечаємося про
те наскільки широкий має бути цей вибір
як залучити до цього усвідомленого
вибору
учнів
як спонукати вчителів щоб вони змогли
сформувати Цю
пропозицію
і Ну я звернув увагу на те що в
більшості кейсів все-таки цей
починається з зацікавленості учня навіть
у цьому оцій складній такій красивій
дуже схемі яка от мене зачепила з яку
показував Метью Це починається такий
Лабіринт складний е який починається теж
все одно з зацікавленості учня який
предмет тобі найбільше подобається а
тоді вже який предмет тобі найкраще
вдається і тоді з'ясувати з учителем чи
чи чи досягнення в цьому предметі
справді мені дозволять далі в свою
перспективу і там є оцей Yes and no Чи
ти маєш чи Уявляєш собі свою майбутню
професію чи ти її ще собі Чи ти ще про
це не не не думає не не не не думаєш Бо
ну ми всі розуміємо що оцей е оце
прагнення до профільної освіти воно має
дуже жорстке обмеження в тому що ці ну
що діти
дорослі не готові часто до того вибору
який їм доводиться робити в житті і тому
в ціложиттєвій перспективі для мене є є
таким важливим цей вибір і в контексті
цього вибору далі
е оте е широка
пропозиція І от по заглиблення занурення
в якусь таку проблематику яка тебе
справді може вивести у світ професій у
світ вого майбутнього якей ти собі Десь
там ще не усвідомлюєш але але якого ти
прагнеш е і в зв'язку з цим в свою чергу
я б звернув увагу ще на таку річ як от
запропонований
андреасом проект проектна
діяльність тут для мене ще є питання які
я сподіваюся впродовж завтрашнього дня
з'ясувати бо Андреас наголошує на тому
що це індивідуальний проект А ми частіше
в коли говоримо про проект ми частіше
думаємо про таку групову роботу і
цінність взаємодії цінність співпраці
так чи інакше важлива але оці
які кожен має нести в проекті очевидно
ну це так я розумію на цю хвилину що це
мабуть йшлося саме про це і останнє що я
хотів би сказати це таке більше
структурне воно
прозвучало прозвучало дуже чітко це 10й
клас
як міст от тут ще залишився пози увагою
сьогодні оцей ірландський кейс коли там
цей 10й клас нібито і не обов'язковий
але всі користаються і йдуть саме цим
містом а не в Брід туди до добираються
до до протилежного берега цікавою була
думка наших польських колег про те що
повернення до чотирирічного ліцею
позбавило їх тієї вади трирічного коли
перший рік - це міст а другий і третій -
це підготовка до матури бо там за
коротка вже залишається перспектива Ми
хочемо міксувати на рівні 10-го класу
щоб там уже і було і по долання прогалин
і орієнтування первинний вибір свого
подальшого шляху і вже так би мовити
початки цього профілювання
але ну от це це такий цікавий виклик
Який теж прозвучав в цьому контексті я
насправді дуже дякую за те що ми маємо
можливість ці речі обговорювати
Дякую дякую дуже і я зараз хочу
звернутися до Андреаса шляйхера ну перш
за все словами великої подяки подяки за
те що по-перше це була дуже швидка
відповідь на запит Міністерства освіти
і підібрати таку експертизу причому з
вибору та Саме таких країн які нам
представили палітру різних систем тут
цінним є те що ми побачили
системи від достатньо ну меншого вибору
до дуже широкого вибору і вони
представили свої сильні слабкі сторони
тому дуже дякуємо от власне за таку
рунтовну
підготовку цієї
презентації А як ви спостерігали це все
наскільки я трошки перефразую своє
запитання саме для вас Андреас бо я не
думаю що ви тут почули якісь особливі
інсайти Мені здається що що ви людина
яка знає все все про всі освітні системи
мабуть абсолютно унікальна
ее
і можливо вас щось вразило в запитаннях
українських
учасників можливо от в наших реакціях Ви
дуже багато приділяєте увагу Україні ви
приїжджаєте в Україну під час війни
особисто ви всім цікавитесь Як ви бачите
е наш наші перспективи в контексті цього
світового
досвіду Дуже дякую ці всі презентації
повні
інсайтів я можу сказати про п'ять
пунктів перше - це знаходження балансу
між глибиною навчання спеціалізацію з
однієї сторони і широтою навчання щоб
була широка база щоб бути універсальними
Україна на одній стороні цього спектру і
має
рухатися до того щоб давати ширшу базу
більше гнучкості більше ідей як це
досягти це вже Інше питання але я думаю
що ті моделі про які ми чули дають
варіанти для цього це перше
спеціалізація або широта навчання
глибина або широта навчання наступне -
це баланс між структурою та
гнучкістю і справді це узгодження вибору
із послідовністю звичайно ми хотіли би
побудувати всю освіту на інтересах та
залученні молоді тому що Це для них це ж
для їхнього майбутнього має служити
освіта їхнім інтересам і а водночас ми
не очікуємо щоб Учні були експертами щоб
вони самі могли робити вибір Отже Мені
подобається як Франція Та Велика
Британія говорить про менторство та
наставництво як ми допоможемо молоді
виявити які ж їхні таланти де я можу
бути справді добрим і робити їм гарні
поради щоб вони зробили значимі вибори
не те вибирати що мене цікавить в даний
момент а те що буде Мені добре
довгостроково протягом життя і це
справді важке питання тому що це
висвітлює що ми очікуємо вчителів щоб не
тільки гарним інструкторам але й
менторами фасилітаторами цікавилися
майбутнім своїх учнів замість того щоб
просто вчити своїми предмети але ж тут
нема легкої відповіді як ми це нам це
все узгодити той вибір який ми хочемо
щоб учні зробили і
також майбутнє їхньої освіти і
послідовність тут є певні приклади
третій пункт
це те
що справді це баланс компроміс між
доступністю та
гнучкістю компроміс Якщо ви хочете щоб
був значимий вибір в
ліцеї треба певний розмір ліцею Якщо ви
хочете певного розміру ліцею їх буде
мало це означає що студентам учням
доведеться подорожувати Отже треба
розглянути як знайти правильний баланс
щоб ліцей був доступний для
учнів і водночас щоб там був гарний
рівень якості та гнучкості я думаю що це
потребує досить трива
розмірковування ми чули від Франції та
Польщі чи часом їм доводиться учням
їздити досить
далеко можливо це гарна інвестиція для
того щоб отримати спеціалізацію та вибір
Але я думаю що треба це пам'ятати
що не так легко зробити цей Круг
квадратом і третя думка
це автономія ліцеїв та реагування на
потреб студентів і це не це не є вально
Отже треба структуризувати пропозицію
ліцеїв і також реагування на потреби
учнів в усьому світі ми на жаль бачимо
що коли є багато автономії на первинному
рівні інституції це використовують для
власних інтересів замість того щоб
дослухатися до того що добре для учнів
коментар від Естонії мені сподобаєся
будемо більш персоналізованими і менш
інституціалізованими це гарний спосіб
щобце сформувати Я думаю що Естонія - це
така держава яка це зробила і останнє що
я почув в декількох промовах як же
узгодити те що є цікаво для учнів і що
важливе для
країни знову ж таки я думаю це не є
тривіально Якщо ви думаєте про наступні
декілька років для України це буде більш
важливо
мати фахівців можливо з антропології але
можливо тут є конфлікт
інтересів і тут говорилося про те що про
фізику Наприклад тут можливо нестача
фізиків На мою
думку відповідь не в тому щоб зробити
фізику обов'язково в тому щоб зробити
фізику цікавою для молоді Треба знайти
шляхи то щоб залучення щоб навчання
більш залучало молодь і не забувати що
важливо для країни це не може бути
просто що студенти вибирають що їм
подобається цього
має бути
узгодження це цікаво для молоді і це
важливо для
країни середньостроково
довгостроково Я думаю що це також
заслуговує на певне
міркування ось мої основні висновки з
цієї
дискусії і
якщо от всі ці висновки прослухати то
воно дуже корелює з
тим як яка співпраця з світовим банком
нам потрібна тому що Наприклад якщо ми
хочемо фізику зробити цікавою і
привабливою для молоді То це означає що
ми її ми маємо вивчати не тільки історію
фізики а й сучасну фізику ми маємо мати
хорошу дослідницьку експериментальну
базу ми маємо підготувати вчителів
сучасним навчити їх сучасним методика
навчання А на це потрібні інвестиції як
і для навчального освітнього середовища
так і для підвищення кваліфікації і тому
зробити реформу справді якісно ми можемо
тільки з такою допомогою так само пошук
цього балансу про який ви кажете щодо
доступу і якості і створення такої
мережі ліцеїв яка б забезпечила цей
баланс це дуже сер рйозне експертне
завдання яке теж буде потребувати
інвестицій тому що ліцеї повинні бути
добре обладнаними там повинні працювати
також висококваліфіковані вчителі а
дітей які живуть далеко і зокрема в селі
Ми маємо мати можливість поселити у
нормальних гуртожитках де вони зможуть
також і проживати біля цих
ліцеїв інакше ми ніяк не долаємо цю
велику прірву яку вже виявила Піза між
сільським сільськими і міськими учнями в
доступі до якісної освіти
і в зв'язку з цим я знову звертаюся до
Джеймса
що які ви бачите перспективи ми завтра
будемо працювати ще один день і зараз
наше друге коло питань якраз про те А
все-таки які амбіції мають бути в нас і
цілі для наступних дискусій що ми
повинні уточнити на вашу думку
які основні рішення повинні повинна
прийняти українська спільнота щоб
рухатися
далі дякую Дуже дякую за це питання за
дискусію Я на жаль приєднався до вас
лише наприкінці сьогоднішнього дня я
знаю що завтра ви продовжите цю
дискусію Я гадаю
що можу погодитися з цими моментами які
щодно задав
Андреас дуже важливе планування на
період до пти
років наша роль в світо світовому банку
полягає в тому щоб підтримувати
уряд
при реалізації планів відновлення після
ковіду і
війни і
безумовно освіта зокрема Старша школа є
частиною цього
відновлення але ми маємо і далі
розвивати
сектор управління має бути сталим і
підготованим до потреб України в
майбутньому
для цього необхідні інвестиції
інвестиції
мають бути заплановані
виміряні і як уряд на центральному рівні
так і місцеві органи самоврядування і
партнери мають поділяти цей погляд на
інвестиції дуже корисно буде
поміркувати це вже спливало під час
дискусії поміркувати
над даними які потрібні це необхідно для
вимірювання для
планування питання Що Україна може
реазувати на центральному рівні які
потрібні стимули інструменти для того
щоб зміни впровадити на місцевому рівні
І не йдеться не тільки про школи а про
роль місцевих органів самоврядування
у підготовці викладавчів як шкільних так
і
університетських загалом реформа Старша
школа - це дуже важлива реформа для
України але вона Тягне за собою багато
потреб і
викликів я
гадаю мій висновок буде такий
необхідно подумати
про основні елементи про послідовні ді
на центральному і на місцевому рівнях і
Світовий банк та інші
партнери зможуть надати фінансування для
реалізації цих елементів також наша роля
буде полявати в тому щоб надавати
необхідні знання досвід на різних
етапах ми проводили вже чимало дискусій
з міносвіти щодо навчання в молодших
класах в межах
нової української школи
але
ми з нетерпінням Очікуємо на продовження
цих дискусій і будемо готові робити все
що в наших силах Дуже дякуємо дуже
дякуємо за відкритість до підтримки змін
в Україні і я хотіла б зараз ще
звернутися до наших панелістів будь
ласка Олександре івановичу А як ви
вважаєте які мають бути завтра зро блені
нами дії в межах цього семінару Ми
намагаємося організувати також групову
роботу на які основні питання на вашу
думку ми би мали дати відповідь
Завтра я думаю що насамперед нам треба
визначитися в тій моделі профільної
середньої
освіти для того щоб все-таки
розуміти що треба зробити тому що на
сьогоднішній день профільна середня
освіта надається в п'ятьма типами
закладів освіти і в законі Про освіту
від 16-го року зміщений акцент ну раніше
теж провтехосвіта і коледжі Які на базі
давали повну загальну середню освіту але
це було зовсім інший хід тобто був
паралельно повно загальносредня освіта
як вона називалася тоді і паралельна
професійна підготовка в законі Про
освіту було вперше проголошено що про
профільна середня освіта має два
спрямування академічне і професійне
спрямування І от в
професійне спрямування потрапляють якраз
ее ті заклади які е здійснювали раніше
але тепер в Новій якості тому ця модель
повинна бути
зрозумілою не лише для академічних
ліцеїв але й для закладів спеціальної
освіти спеціалізованої Пробачте освіти
для професійних закладів освіти е і тут
ми повинні виробати державний стандарт
такий щоб він задовольняв і всі два ці
напрями навіть більше бо якщо якщо взяти
ще і спеціалізовану освіту то вона має
окремий
такий гілочку яку теж треба забезпечити
тому і звичайно нам
треба визначитися в тому
е наборі будемо так казати
інваріантного змісту який буде спільний
для всіх е
тобто то або перелік предметів
або освітні галузі тут треба зробити
вибір яки якимсь чином і відповідно до
цього
е Якщо завтра я буду
презентувати одну з
можливих моделей яку розробили в
національній Академії педогогічних Наук
ми її опублікували у віснику нашому в
академії він вже оприлюднений багато
людей ознайомились з ним але я закцентую
на тих питаннях які саме стосується оцих
двох аспектів модель Ось і зміст е
Дякуємо звісно ми
е на цій події не
охоплюємо професійні ліцеї не охоплюємо
професійний напрямок старшої профільної
школи це не було метою мета була
заявлена саме про
ее
ліцеї академічного спрямування і ми
зараз про них говоримо але і завтрашній
день теж їм буде присвячений саме їм це
лише свідчить про одне що нам потрібна
ще ширша дискусія і ми не можемо
обмежитися лише цією зустріччю тому але
її завжди потрібно сфокусувати щоб
досягнути результату я думаю що саме от
ці питання які ви поставили щойно
Олександру івановичу про власне і вибі і
про спільне ядро предметів яке повинно
бути для всіх і до речі для академічного
і для професійного напрямку це стане теж
предметом дискусії завтра будь ласка
Романе Романе
Богдановичу ваші очікування Що ви
вважаєте ми маємо завтра обов'язково
обговорити Ну я хочу от до кінця
з'ясувати що стоїть за оцією ідеєю про
проекти бо це дає ву відповідь на ті
питання які перед нами стоять
е щодо от власне поглиб поглибленого
занурення
ее для мене відверто кажучи немає питань
в самому змісті тому що ну номенклатура
галузей і ці результати навчання які там
описані у відповідні До ключових
компетентностей як я вже згадував з них
ми починали І от в усіх цих кейсах були
такі інституційні домівки для усіх ну
розділів нашого стандарту там були
відповіді вони може були неявними Але
можна було це все побачити в таблицях
для мене завтра важливо було б з'ясувати
власне і сформулювати чіткіше це в
державному стандарті в проекті як має
здійснюватися оцей вибір і в зв'язку з
цим як мають
формуватися
профілі От і дуже сподіваюся що
Та інспірація яку ми отримали впродовж
сьогоднішнього дня Нам дозволить це
зробити Дякую Дякую Ну і знову ж слово
на
завершення натхненнику нашому пану
андреасу
е Я скажу відверто андреасу Що мені
сьогодні трошки не
вистачило у чудових презентаціях які
були з різних країн але мені не
вистачило Питання все-таки Форму вання
наскрізних
компетентностей тих які називають
м'якими навичками тому що це
один один з наголосів нашої реформи нова
українська школа і я вважаю що це може
бути таким нашим ну певним національним
е змістом і національною ознакою нашої
реформи
е як ми можемо підступитися до цього
питання власне на рівні старшої
профільної школи
так я
гадаю що навіть м'якими навичками їх не
називати Я думаю що багато з твердих
навичок
століття стали м'якими
2 багато
навичок але не потрібними і навпаки
багато м'яких навичок минулого століття
стали обов'язковими в цьому правда
подумайте про себе Ви працюєте з людьми
які відрізняються від вас Ви маєте
справу із двозначністю якщо ви Спитаєте
роботодавця в Україні то він одразу
зрозуміє що ви маєте на увазі про які
які навички ви говорите і ми
часто Відрізняємо ці навички від
академічних дисциплін але вони є
важливою складовою академічних дисциплін
треба зрозуміти що не просто необхідно
навчити дітей наприклад зматися якимось
спорто але треба їх навчити брати на
себе відповідальність проявляти
сміливість тощо або навчання в
математиці передбачає Передбачає
розвиток цікавості і Жаги до
дослідження Я вже не кажу про
соціальноемоційні навички когнітивні
навички це ми їх називаємо позапрограмні
навички або ще якось а от візьмемо
наприклад власні студентські проекти це
чудові чудовий
підхід Візьміть шкільний урок 45 хвилин
і все скінчилося Але якщо це проект то
треба прийняти рішення щодо проекту і
триматися його до кінця часом треба
просити по допомогу питати про
рекомендації працювати з іншими для того
щоб розв'яз
задачі і учні в таких проектах
розвивають необхідні здібності для цього
там є багато простору щодо очікувань на
завтра Я глибоко переконаний що завтра у
нас буде цікава дискусія з приводу
концепції дизайну експерти добре на
цьому знають Це ми постійно прагнемо до
самовдосконалення проте часом Ми через
це втрачаємо етап імплементації
реалізації так не так складно сформувати
концепцію як її реалізувати насправді на
практиці Я думаю що завтра ми зможемо
окреслити справжню траєкторію до
реалізації
багато реформ сповнені чудових ідей які
зазнали поганої
реалізації
треба починати все з самого початку коли
ми лише розробляємо концепцію треба вже
продумати як ця концепція буде вцілена У
реальності і цим мають займатися школи
дуже на дуже ранніх етапах можливо треба
залучати
вчителів до дизайну але це не не завжди
допоможе вам при реалізації треба
залучати саме тих людей які будуть потім
працювати на прак
вже на етапі розробки
необхідно мати на меті майбутню
реалізації правда нам не подобається
коли нам кажуть як щось треба робити Нам
подобається вже безпосередньо щось
робити знаємо що дуже багато є фахівців
які
можуть реалізувати це на практиці і Як
казав пан Олександр У нас є потреби
потреби в даних наприклад треба розуміти
що слід робити І це не складно ми можемо
запитати учнів керівництво шкіл
вчителів необхідно зрозуміти які є
потреби і Питання в тому як
розбудовувати спроможності для того щоби
люди могли почати свій освітній шлях Я
сподіваюся що під час завтрашньої
дискусії ми обговоримо достатньою мірою
всі ці практичні моменти
які сьогодні були залучені до цього
вебінару тому що кожна презентація була
надзвичайно цінною і ми крім того
вважаємо що всі колеги які взяли участь
вони є нашими друзями нашими партнерами
тими хто вболівають за Україну і ми Щиро
дякуємо за цю підтримку передаю Дякую
панелістам передаю тепер мікрофон будь
ласка Пане Ігоре Дякую щиро колеги я
дуже-дуже швидко одне один блок
організаційних коротких зауважень і одне
концептуально важливе організаційне на
виході
з цієї аудиторії там де ви реєструвалися
ви можете взяти друкований примірник чи
то англійською чи то українську версію
рекомендації візії Андреаса шляйхера
стосовно моделі академічних ліцеїв
можливої в Україні ви можете
ознайомитися вдома для того щоб нам ми
плідно могли обговорювати і можливо ще
якісь додаткові інсайти мали також
Нагадую що за qr-кодами У папці яка є на
зворотному боці qr-код є вашого бейджа
будуть всі цифрові версії презентації і
також цей візійний документ так само е
ще одне організаційне завтра о з 8:30 до
9ї в нас буде вітальна кава ми розуміємо
що зранку вона просто життєво необхідна
і тоді ми перейдемо о 9тій до
безпосередньої роботи в групах Ну і на
сам кінець концептуально важливе Я б
хотів від імені Міністерства освіти і
науки України подякувати по-перше
організації економічного співробітництва
і розвитку і зокрема андреасу шляйхеру і
попросити ваших
оплесків
за експертизу якої годі будьде шукати
також ніicef за підтримку в організації
проведення цього
заходу моїй співмодераторці сьогодні
натхненниці ледь не всього в українській
освіті Лілі Михайлівні
Гриневич а також важливо концептуально з
нами сьогодні в залі Я просто хотів щоб
ви щоб ми відчули і по аплодували одне
одному Та в нас представники крім
експертних крім експертів яких ми
сьогодні чули крім зазначених
організацій представники МЗС Фінляндії
інститутів післядипломної педагогічної
освіти директори шкіл приватних і
державних
університет педагогічний заклади вищої
освіти громадський сектор
найрізноманітніші організації тому такпа
артаменти обов'язково Тому я б хотів щоб
ви поаплодували одне
одному Дякую щиро а і Міністерство
освіти і науки України залишається
завжди з вами Дякую щиро і до зустрічі
завтра з нетерпінням
чекаємо